We are live.
That's it.
Hello Jordan.
How's it going?
Joe?
Let's costs if professional video game player,
you what's up dude?
You live in the dream.
That's what every teenage boy who's sitting in front of his parents television
and is you fucking loser.
Get some shit done with your life.
That's actually how I pick up girls.
I go on Tinder and I say I'm living the dream so they don't actually see that.
I say I played professional game.
I just said living the dream.
Yeah,
but it's like,
what's your dream?
The childhood dream.
Everyone's like,
well if your boy,
I guess.
Right.
Well when you first started playing video games,
was there any professional option?
Um,
well kind of.
There's these teams,
team three d that was the first big team in North America and they like,
I remember going to a local fries and a buying a keyboard and seeing like one of
their players quotes on the box.
Like I use this keyboard because I'm going to be the fucking best with this
keyboard.
Sounds like awesome.
Like that was actually super big part of my motivation.
Like,
I want to be on a box
now.
When you first started playing,
like how old were you?
Uh,
I think I was nine when my brother and she used to,
I have two older brothers.
My oldest brother was playing counterstrike and of course I wasn't allowed to
play so I'm sitting there watching him play all day.
And you weren't allowed to put no,
it was his computer.
So he's like,
he out,
he was like shoot me out of Israel.
And then I'd kind of like crawl on the floor,
walk in and like try to like watch him like getting his room and watch.
And then when he would leave he'd go to school or something.
I would hop on his computer and I would play counter strike is a weird one
because that was,
it was first it was halflife halflife team death match.
Yeah.
And then like no one even talks about half life game.
Then it became,
counterstrike was like the big game,
the pupil.
So death match when you're playing death match counterstrike,
you playing one on one or team versions of the halflife engine,
but against other people.
That's what a lot of people that play Cassia competitively used to like warm up
death match mode cause you just keep dying in responding.
It's like a quake is to give or something,
you know,
you just keep restarting and just kill each other to kind of warm up your,
your hands and whatnot.
Getting working well together.
Do you,
do you have like a ritual or anything you do before you,
uh,
you play?
Well,
I mean it is muscle memory at his calisthenics.
I at this point though,
like obviously if you're a golfer you might not train as hard as you did when
you wanted to make the tour,
but you still have to do maintenance stuff.
So like when I hit a death match,
I'd get maybe a hundred kills with each gun.
And then I just did obviously have team practice,
which is a different set of coordinating strategies and stuff.
But for personally,
yeah,
I just try to make sure I'm still playing self.
I ever feel off.
I could identify what's really off pretty quick and I'll just go hone in on that
guy or that part of a map or whatever.
But uh,
yeah,
it's,
it's a mix of both.
Do you think that people don't respect how difficult it is to play competitive
video games?
Cause yeah,
definitely.
I mean it's fucking really difficult.
Like the,
the level of competence,
their level of skill.
Like if you've watched,
uh,
you can watch a lot of games online and that's like
a big part of all this now,
which is really fascinating is how many people watch live games or even with
quake,
the big thing was watching demos.
Yeah.
People would watch demos was really good players.
You do that too?
Yeah,
I think,
I think part of it obviously is people don't know what the effect they're
looking at outside perspective.
So like certain games I can understand starcraft or league of legends or what
are our calf you're looking at least spells flying around.
That's ridiculous.
Those,
those like action key moments normally happen over the course of like 10 minutes
or something.
Whereas in counterstrike or quake,
it's like that guy just got that point.
He's about to kill this guy.
There's this 30 seconds left on the clock.
So I think that's actually more intuitively easy for a spectator to watch as a
spectator sport.
But you're right.
Yeah.
A lot of people I don't think comprehend what you go through that Oh this kid
just plays all day for fun and doesn't think about what he's doing.
He just happened to be good.
Yeah.
It's always been fascinating to me how certain games get,
they get taken seriously.
Like certain games garner respect like chess.
If you were really good chess player,
like oh he's a sophisticated gentleman.
He's a chess player.
Yeah.
What do you do for a living?
Oh I played chess.
Whoa,
interesting.
What do you do for living?
Oh I played video games.
Oh you fucking door counterstrike,
right.
I've got,
I've progressed over that and I played cachet with the fuck.
It's Kinda shake.
Yeah.
Well I do this.
Well that's extra geeky cause your name in the video where you have to,
cause you say play video games.
It's like saying you played pro sports.
Right,
right,
right.
That's true.
So I tried to make that distinction to do justice to my,
my profession or whatever.
So in the future people start questioning more about what I do now.
What level is the,
I mean obviously there's halflife that came out and then was the game engine
continually upgraded?
Yeah,
like I started playing in like Beta version.
So Beta 5.2 Beta is basically before the game is full released,
right.
You don't know what a Beta is.
There's like Alphas and Beta.
Right.
And then the full release.
So I played Beta before.
It's even a game,
a full version in stores and uh,
yeah all the weapons are different.
And then 1.0 1.1 1.3 the longest lasting version was 1.6 which I went pro in
back in like two.
I went pro in 2008 but it went the how that you can go pro if so join the light
I or you have to pay for anything,
sign up for stuff.
Well there there is a process.
It's not a conventional,
when like sports you don't get to like a high school team and college team.
It's,
it's,
there's no coaches in east sports will recently there are but like that's
coaches recently and that we'll get into that.
But like you know how obviously if you're going to play in NHL you try to like
Joe for play for a college team or you go to juniors or semi pro age though.
In this case there is like I finally caught usea they have the open division,
intermediate main from your invite.
If you're an invite,
you're really the only people that have a chance that can get paid to play by
companies.
So when I say I went pro back in 2008 it's because I joined up a contract with
an organization called evil geniuses,
which is like my agency for an actor and they had sponsors from Intel,
new egg,
a bunch of peripheral companies for my gear and they pay me to fly to the
tournament and I had market them like I'm a Nascar car,
I have their logos all over them.
I tell people why their gear is good,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Wow.
Okay.
So now that's the counterstrike,
uh,
the,
the halflife engine.
So what is,
is there a several versions of it that they've come up with?
Like what,
what version are you on now?
So now it's the most recent called global offensive.
Uh,
is this a new version of counterstrike itself or new version?
There's not a new version.
Halflife right?
Nope.
They came out with halflife two at one point,
but that,
that was the source engine.
So counterstrike came,
it was on that end.
So for folks who don't know what the fuck we're talking about,
this is what that means.
Like video game engines,
they take the engine like the three d geometry,
the video,
like the way it looks,
the graphics,
and then they take that engine and then they can port it over to other games and
they can develop games based on that engine.
So it cuts a lot of the development process out because a big part of the
development process out is coming up with a,
a video game engine.
Yup.
So yeah,
they have I think half life to you.
I don't know when exactly came out,
if he was like 2004 or five that's kind of old.
No,
that was that 10 years ago.
Like I said,
I went pro and countered at 1.6 and that was like everyone loved it.
It was like the original quake,
like the registration of like my bullet shooting and I hit a guy like it.
It worked,
it hit him when he shot him in the head,
like some of these new versions of the counselors that were coming out,
it was almost too easy.
Like you would shoot a bullet like right here because the guy was moving weird.
He would still registered as a headshot.
So that was something was up with the engine and it,
it was like they were trying to up the graphics and the feel and to make it look
more realistic.
But that took away from I guess how fast the computer talks to the server,
you know?
So then there was a discrepancy between like when I shot,
when it actually hit the person.
And obviously that's why like I can't,
when I practice,
I can't play against Europeans because of Internet lag.
Right.
So that's why you would play on a land because that's the fastest interaction
between the server and played on online with the Internet lag and you get used
to it and then you play without the lag.
It's like you go to paradise.
Yeah.
It's like having to wait on your baseball bat or something.
But some guys got really good at it.
Like some guys get super good at timing their own fuck up their own lag.
Yeah.
That's bullshit though.
Cause then they're harder to hit.
Some of them are just glitching around it.
Bull Shit.
So that's annoying.
So at our level we're really like Prima donnas about like what server,
location,
what we planned because my teammates are spread around the country so don't play
on like a Denver a server and you have to make sure that you're paying is very
low.
Right.
Like the pink to the server.
Yeah.
I mean like what's,
what's a Good Ping these days?
Well playing in north,
playing in North America for counterstrike player like 40 to 50 is like what we
play on.
But like if I were to plan a southern in La,
Los Angeles saver from San Diego,
I get 15 cause I'm closer.
But as a team,
since we're all spread out,
we're in,
we're in like Toronto and all this stuff across the country.
We play centralized and that's a milliseconds.
So it'd be like 15 milliseconds at I guess.
So does that register in your head?
You'd notice a difference between 15 and 40?
Well,
I could feel it.
It's really just like the,
uh,
the gun itself.
I could feel it's like a very small,
like a lot of people don't notice a difference for the first couple of years.
They probably play the game.
But once you start realizing the different action of the recoil of the guns,
you could feel it between each bullet.
This is super nerdy.
Yeah.
I know you played claims.
We'll talk about that later.
Yeah.
Um,
so my question is like,
how do you decide what game to become super adept at?
Because it seems like there's a lot of you become adept at it but I mean the
games have a life like were people won't play them anymore.
Like it gets to a point like try playing quake one today.
Troy,
what happened with kind of sugar 1.6 so this was Kinda,
it was kind of what I was kind of talking about.
The new version came out and because 1.6 is getting stagnant like that,
since the developer doesn't give back to the game much and there isn't a shit
coming out,
people are like wow,
this gets old because they're not pro,
they're playing for the fun of it.
That's the people that helped me make this.
My job is the 80 or 90% of the community who isn't pro who plays in is my
viewership is the people I talked to for my sponsors,
et cetera.
So that was going downhill out at the end of counterstrike and other games like
League of legends,
which is not a first person shooter and a Dota.
These are like five [inaudible],
five strategies spells and like that's different type of stuff.
That's when they lose me.
Yeah.
And so yes,
I've played counter strike is I just loved the intuitive finesse you could bring
to the game.
It wasn't just like chess,
it was more of like a chest to tennis or whatever you want to say.
I could actually,
I could just out skill someone simply,
even if they do a crazy strategy,
I'm just gonna stand there and say,
well I'll,
I'll shoot you every time.
Even if you think you're smarter,
just your hand eye coordination and your understanding of where the mouse is
going to move the cursor.
And I find a lot of people who play counter strike were more physically fit
people.
Like there's an archetype to different pro gamers.
A lot of people think everyone's a fat pimply guy.
Well,
I notice a lot of counterstrike players like myself grew up playing sports.
I played ice hockey.
All my youth,
a lot of my teammates are team athletes.
Um,
or just,
well,
the dorks like starcraft.
I know I'm going to go to work pat for condom dark.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
So,
and the thing is I have friends in those realms too.
Right.
So there are those,
those random people you got into quake yourself,
right.
There's all sorts of different people get into games,
but generally,
yeah,
the people,
it's like chess.
Starcraft is more a cerebral game.
You're,
you're kind of premeditating a lot of your decisions,
which you are encountering it too,
but in a much more strategic way.
You don't need to,
you could probably plug in any mouse and play starcraft.
Whereas when my sponsor tries to give me a new mouse,
I like resist a lot because that's like,
I don't know,
different baseball glove or a different pair,
a different curve from ice hockey sticker.
Different set of irons as a golfer,
like it really throws me off for a little bit.
Or they all laser mice now.
Yeah,
but some obstacles work well if the surface is one color,
if the surface is a multicolored on a mouse,
it actually makes tracking harder.
Like these people have these crazy designs and their mouse bag that's actually
detrimental to like the tracking and stuff.
Really?
Yeah.
But no one uses a ball anymore.
Start on a ball.
You open that shit up.
Yeah.
Remember you have to,
I used to have Q tips with alcohol and he used to have a clean the little
rollers cause they gunk up with sweat and funk.
Oh Joe is a Gamer.
He was,
he was addicted to that thing.
And I have a question.
If you're so good at counterstrike,
can you pick up most first person shooters and be really good at it on PC?
Yeah.
On PC.
So you can go into grand theft auto right now and just kill everybody.
Yeah.
That's not really a competitor,
but yeah,
exactly.
Yeah,
probably do that.
I'm quake.
I used to play quake all time.
Rocket Arena.
Three quakes.
Yeah.
So you just have like really good understanding of what movement of your hand
corresponds to the movement on the screen.
You get kind of a feeling.
Yeah,
just good dexterity.
Most frustration shooters are just like you said,
I heard you talking about quake and it's really just intuitive.
Like you play at first and you're like,
oh,
I have to look with my mouse hand in this and yeah,
after awhile it's like an extension of your hands.
I don't think I do a lot of actions per minute that I don't even comprehend
because I'm reacting visually.
Not Mentally.
Yeah,
I'd get there was a,
there's like gun switches and moves that you would do that literally would come
like tying your shoes.
Yeah.
And then you start playing better
players.
You manipulate those little things that like there's,
there's,
that's what we call the Meta game is things that like,
it changes constantly because it's all based on intuition.
Right.
That's why it's so weird when you switch from game to game.
That was why I had that question.
Because like if you've got super into counterstrike and then you know,
like maybe,
you know,
have you seen the teaser for the new doom?
No.
Oh,
we should pull out yet.
Oh Shit.
And Jamie does a new doomed.
I'm fucking,
I worship at the altar of John Carmack.
Yes.
Yeah.
He's the baddest motherfucker ever when it comes to this shit.
But there's new doom.
The graphics are just so ridiculous.
It's just like fucking Christ now while right?
Yeah,
it's been awhile.
I mean he's been doing a bunch of different kinds of video games as well,
but I remember when the here,
let's,
let's play it real quick and we'll show you this cause this is,
this is really crazy.
It'll be to the left to use or to the right of you as well.
We just play it on that.
Then it doesn't matter.
Go Fullscreen.
Jamie blast.
Peggy 18 what are those?
That's all you get these serious,
that's it.
That's it.
That's all you get.
June 14th they're going to show a game play that has the June for the job.
Won't time June 14th you get to see the actual full thing being played.
I guess.
What are you doing?
Switching things on us.
Pull it again.
Can't hear it.
Three yeah,
we need to duck done.
Maybe 18 welcome to hell.
Oh,
that's dope.
Cue The pay Tara.
But like when you would play that,
like if you play that game and you got used to that physics,
like I remember going from quake to unreal,
it was like screw you up a little.
Even though it was awesome,
it was like,
it moved just a little different.
The mouse cursor have moved a little different and you know,
you,
you get your settings and you try to like fidget with it and try to get it to a
place where you kind of understand what was happening intuitively.
So that yeah,
it's always that we always rate when we get a new game,
that's a first person shooter and you go in and see how the game takes your
sensitivity if it's directly from your mouse or from windows.
So that's called raw input.
So some games have Ron put where it takes your mouse and CV and I can go and
dial it basically ended out my cash drag fields seven down.
So something you have to go in and like they have their own.
Um,
uh,
it's like they're on in game since taking game sensitivity and you have to slide
the notch.
We had and it's got to tell an extrapolation of what a default sensors and every
time you move one notch,
it's 1.25 the original versus another David.
And then there's mouse acceleration,
which is fucking gonna turn that off.
Obviously the faster,
but some guys were really loved it.
Like the faster you move the hand it corresponded to a different type of
movement with the mouse.
Yeah.
Whereas like under normal circumstances,
you move left,
you move right and the cursor moves left to right and it's independent on
whether or not you move fast.
But if you fast with mouse acceleration,
it moves way faster.
Onscreen extra spin to it at the end it's like,
it's almost like it's a gyroscope or something like that or it's like it's got
some momentum to it.
Yeah.
When,
when,
uh,
if you noticed,
so with first person shooters,
a lot of people set their arm differently on the desk.
So people,
some people play with risks,
so their Congress party,
so this is like the hand or wrist Amer,
right.
[inaudible] has a risk kind of sat down.
And when they're,
when they're moving they have risk tamer,
wrist,
Amer,
Amer.
And then I'm more of an elbow.
My elbow is my hand.
Should I have more control?
So I use a lower sensitivity.
Right.
Oh okay.
I can walk faster.
Swipe larger swipes,
someone playing with their risk is doing this.
So these are higher sensitivity.
Some of those people don't mind using a little excel because they could do these
little like flick moves and kind of just really get into the groove with that.
And it's smaller.
Whereas I have bigger emotions that make me more comfortable.
So if I have a little bit of excel,
I just,
I want it to be as true as possible to my actual hand cause I'm doing these
bigger movements to have a large mouse pad as well.
Uh,
yeah.
But I actually have two on top of each other.
I'm one of the few people he uses like a hard mousepad versus just cloth.
It's not like the plastic feel and I have to like replace it like every three
months because I grind it down like my sponsors are like sending me down.
How many hours you plan a day Sun do you get outside?
You know about Vitamin Dane?
Yeah,
that's it.
I went San Diego man,
you know I'm outside.
There you go.
But like how many hours do you have to play a day to stay fit?
Um,
well when we're going to say fit in the loose,
I mean,
but it is a sort of push.
That's right.
But it is a sort of in shape for the game.
Calisthenics.
Just like,
yeah,
when I take a vacation I come back,
I'm like Whoa,
this looks weird for sampling.
Yeah,
for a couple of weeks even I just come back but I get into a quick,
um,
we have a turn at coming up since it's very centric,
like we dry
run,
we premeditate a does in strategies on the counters and on a terror side,
like you really try to memorize what you and your teammates are going to do.
So if something is thrown a wrench into your gears,
you have to react on the fly somewhat within a certain scale of thought.
So when I played for Turner,
that's like we get on at 3:00 PM we ended 11 yes.
Yeah.
So whoa,
Jesus Christ.
What about food?
Water,
bathroom breaks.
This is why I spelled it the arc type.
No,
like for instance,
when we do these boot camps,
three out of five of us at least wake up and go to the gym.
We wake up in the gym,
shower,
we play on our own like dice,
match,
chill,
eat and then like take down like hour before they make sure when you play on
your own,
when you're saying you play on your own match,
what does that mean to you?
Connect to a public server may maybe under an alias so people don't give a shit
because everyone knows her names in the game.
So we'll like go into a death match kind of hidden and I just like you just
kill,
respond,
death matches and like a real mode.
Like we don't care about her stats were just just having fun.
We might like sometimes I purposely look away from a doorway so when if some guy
comes through at our practice,
a 90 degree turn and hitting him in the head.
So I just constantly,
I have my back to a guy so when he comes I could hear him and I fuck around.
And that's the thing that a lot of people don't know about video games is that
you can hear in three dimensions too.
Like if something's coming back behind you,
back to your right,
you can actually hear it back into your right,
which is really spooky.
Yeah,
yeah.
We use sound all the time to manipulate things or we make it seem like they
didn't hear or like we don't know they're behind us.
I'll run out this doorway and I know a guy's cha trailing me.
So when I rented the last of my teammates on the right,
waiting for him to come shoot me in the last.
So like we manipulate sound all the time.
So it's,
yeah,
it's a huge part of it.
So are you guys,
when you plan out your strategies,
do you guys,
like,
do you have like a video chat where you go over like the strategies in,
in physical form or do you write it out?
Like how do you,
so obviously first of all,
when sometimes when we boot camp,
we're on the same location.
So we have a big turn in Stockholm and we'd go to Stockholm 10 days in advance
and we go to,
that's the best teams in counterstrike or in Europe.
That's just where they are on.
Our team has never,
my team is,
I've won a couple world championships and the old game,
but I've never been a world champion a new game yet.
Like we,
cause it's a team game and like we get,
we'll get to semis or something,
but those guys are the shit and I'm on friends and all of them.
But that point aside,
um,
wonder why Europe?
Wait,
what was the question?
Is it,
um,
you were talking about Jesus,
what was the original question?
Um,
you're getting together [inaudible] your strategy.
So yeah,
so on offense,
you dry rotting in a server,
we all connect to the same private server and we just,
um,
basically were like,
okay,
we're going to take this bomb site.
What number ways can we do it?
If we have a full economy?
Meaning do we have every grenade in our arsenal?
Do we have no grenades?
So we have to dry walk in.
We say dry when we have nothing to really assist us.
No smoke grenades,
no flash.
So we say,
hey,
we're going to three dry walk into this bomb site.
You to watch our flank.
So that means they're not going to throw anything like,
right.
So like if we're going to hit this room right here and we're going to come in
and kill Joe Rogan,
if we wanted to come in here,
we'd sell a flash bang through that door.
Right?
And then we had smell smoke off the kitchen right here.
So no one in the kitchen has a vision on the people coming through that doorway.
And then you know,
we expect only angles that can hold her under that TV and behind where,
yeah,
where he sitting back here,
Jamie.
I had his name.
I want to say Riley for some reason Jamie and so yeah.
So yeah,
exactly.
Riley Riley
about of names.
Right?
Um,
so you will out but we have no grenades.
Obviously we're coming into Joe Studio Dry,
right?
The Lube.
So these strategies are based upon the g,
the geometry of the room,
type of the map,
how fast.
If we have things called fakes where we'll throw everything in here and make it
look like we're coming to kill you.
And all of a sudden the three of us are taking your teammates out who we were.
We're catching on the rotation cause we're saying when we throw all the shit in
this room,
Joe is going to say,
guys,
they're coming in,
which is going to cause your guys watching the outback to come towards you and
help you.
And then we're going to,
we're going to jump them in the backyard.
And so these strategies are all planned out in advance names for them?
Yeah.
So we'll call it like sonic or Gatorade or,
and they take hold and you can hear each other but you can't hear them.
Yeah we connect to a third party software like mumble or teamspeak.
It's kind of like Skype but you pass a hot key.
It's like a walkie talkie and so you will talk to each other while you're
playing the game.
Look,
look around and he's behind you.
Cause anybody hack into your line and they can like find out what you're saying.
Back in the day.
That was kind of like a thing that would happen between friends.
Like you're playing,
you do,
we call him 10 man's where you pick two captains and everyone throws her name
and a hat and you play random five verse five teams and you're all in the same
voice.
Several.
Well one guy will,
you can,
you can clone the program and opened it again and he'll come in and join your
channel wise playing.
So I'll have like one year,
I don't know what you guys are doing and that's like a scummy thing for it to do
to each other person.
But when we're playing at a pro level it can't happen cause her isolated.
Now with online gaming,
one of the things that was a real problem with quake was bots was people that
would have aiming bots couldn't miss and you would get on a server and some guy
would be shooting guys that were like jumping through the air like shooting.
You couldn't miss it did kill everybody.
They have that with counterstrike.
Yup.
There's wall hacking and ain't bought.
So we'll have little hack is just obviously transparent walls.
See those guys are pieces of shit and they ain't bought,
he's a shit.
Right.
So we've all,
like I say,
a majority of pros have messed around with it for fun with their friends.
Like Yo guys let's go cheat verse each other and see how gnarly it is.
And like we used to do that back in the old versions and the new game.
You can't even screw around if they cause they have such a crazy anti cheat,
which is what I was just going to say now.
It's really hard to do that.
You have to literally,
it's like actually a big,
it's a multimillion dollar industry cheating and competitive games.
It's not like a huge,
huge industry,
but people sell like they update it every time the game developer creates a
better like firewall or whatever for the cheats they like go in and look at the
code,
make it find a way around it to do there.
Even by it Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Obviously at pro level I don't do you know cheaters,
oh that's actually wrong,
but last year there was the first ever time at a pro level where people found a
way to cheat in.
The guy got banned for life from tournaments,
lights for fucking life because he cheated at like a land qualifiers,
bulls.
He land local area network.
Where were all,
they were like,
it's a French player and he literally got caught.
It's like the smallest cheat ever found.
They found a way to like,
it's like 50 kilobytes and they inserted it and like it was like a trigger
bought so it wasn't a fulltime ane bought.
So he could press a button and it would snap to the nearest enemy.
So even if they're behind a wall,
so he could be chilling and just press this button and it would like snap to the
wall.
And you knew a guy was about to come around in that corridors and it was super
low key but super scummy.
How'd the catch him?
Um,
I forget the series of events,
but there was some like red flag on his account and then like the people have
the ability to like go s s zoom in and narrow their scope onto one account and
like scan their system.
And they did that and they found some shady traces of like cheating.
And then he admitted it and he's like,
I'm sorry guys,
I can't lie anymore.
Wow.
And so now he's done for the rest of his life.
What if it comes back with a different name?
Halo?
I mean,
we'd see his face.
We know what if he gets plastic surgery,
plastic surgery yet,
right.
That's the surgery is pretty epic.
Couldn't go,
just apologize.
That's what he did formally.
But the thing is is it's like pretty scummy.
Like that's like someone,
it's not only writing that would be like having jet packs on your feet playing
football,
like and almost like poisoning the opponent.
Yeah.
It's,
it's not,
yeah.
It's not just [inaudible] that's like God power.
This is like Nancy Kerrigan.
Yeah.
Like you remember Nancy Kerrigan and Tonya Harding.
We're Tonya Harding and hired someone to whack Nancy Kerrigan and the legs like
the next level of scumbag.
That's next level shit.
So,
um,
so there's very few ways that a person could cheat in the professional realm.
There's things like,
say you have a little mini map or radar,
you can make it so all the other teams shows up on their mate radar too.
So you could find out where you're,
so when you're playing,
you know where your guys are in any given moment.
Yeah,
exactly.
You could make a hack.
So other people dots,
right.
Moving around.
And the rotating map and what's your username mates?
You can make it to all 10 people in the game show up or whatever,
money area.
But if you tried to do that professionally and you'd get banned for like,
Oh yeah,
like you might be able to have a button at toggles it on and off and like if no
admin is watching you,
but when you played a tournament,
do you have like people walking behind you that so crazy.
Now,
what kind of money is involved in this now?
So which facet of it,
right?
What can like,
okay,
give me the top of the food chain first.
Like what's the top of the food chain video game or make per year?
Uh,
well,
so I play counterstrike rights and remember legal legends countering league of
legends is huge right now.
League of legends,
League of legends because the game developer themselves was,
didn't even know what that is.
Like a superhero game.
FIVERR's five.
It's like,
it's like don't,
I don't know if you've heard of dota either.
It's Fiverr's five overview.
Um,
you,
you go one end of the corner of the map through three different lanes and yeah,
it spells and different heroes.
I'm only interested in first person.
Yeah.
So that's the way more exciting.
That overhead view shit.
Well,
regardless I those people,
that's like you said,
I've always been at first person shooters,
but yeah,
those games,
they,
their developer was the first one to really get involved with the competitive
community and give a bunch of prize money back like $10 million tournaments,
like insane.
So like some of these players in the past couple of years have made like over a
million dollars each because of those tournaments.
But if you're talking like the average salary of League of legends player,
they're all making a couple hundred grand a year,
six figures,
no shit.
So that's for the top guys.
Yes.
So like for me and my teammates,
we can all make six figure salaries,
see your parents who've got to fucking respect that.
Right.
At a certain point in time,
you know,
we'll go,
mom,
do you know what a lawyer makes?
Okay,
I make that.
So go tell your fucking friends.
I'm a lawyer,
I got a call back.
Yeah,
I had costs parents.
Luckily like my dad was kind of the reality check.
But in a positive way like you realize that this is kind of a volatile career,
like you're probably going to like not,
this might not apply to anything after you done competing.
Luckily for me,
I've done a lot of little things that I kind of have some connections but yeah,
I'm assuming you were going to be done competing.
I assume need to not just addicted to life but,
no,
but that's the thing is uh,
yeah,
you don't know what it's going to be but my mom was always like,
I credit why I went pro to kind of her being cool with me.
Like she would drive me to Las Vegas from San Diego,
Arizona,
northern California because she saw how into it I was and I was like,
and I included her on it.
I think that was a big thing for any of you out there who want to like pursue
gaming.
You can't just like fucking ignore everything in your life and get bad grades
and do all this shit in school.
You have to like balance stuff.
Right?
So like I was kind of like a nerd in that sense.
At a young age I played ice hockey,
came home,
did my schoolwork,
played counter strike the rest of the night.
And I told my mom every night who I'm playing with,
what team,
what level I'm at.
And so when I finally said,
hey mom,
I can go to this tournament,
I'm old enough because they had an age limit,
like it'd be 15 I was like,
I really want to go.
And so she started driving me and like pretty soon after I was making a name for
myself on the west coast.
Like there's this little kid,
sounds like a girl.
He's fucking fucking everybody up.
He's like little Munchkin and he's just,
he's insane at the game individually.
But obviously you need to be a good team player.
So everyone kind of spread my name,
but my mom was,
yeah,
right.
They're driving me to these lands.
I would play,
we'd get there at like 10:00 AM in Irvine or something and she would be knitting
and hanging out,
go see a movie,
come back,
pick me up at 2:00 AM driving home to San Diego.
So crazy.
No,
like starcraft is still a huge game.
That guy's awesome stands for right now.
It's probably first league of legends and DOTA and counter strike us three.
Wow.
So Star Trek,
but star trying to hit a plateau.
2012.
What was that about?
I think,
well I don't,
yeah,
I don't know that exactly why.
Just twitch really blew it up.
So twitch is streaming,
right?
Like you stream twitch blew it up because the twitches of website where people
stream the games.
Yeah.
I don't know if you watched the video games being played.
It's like Webcam
models for gamers where these guys are making thousands and thousands of dollars
an hour just for playing video games on twitch and you get tips and donations
and all the hips.
So yeah,
exactly.
I work,
uh,
in some cases on my d squirt on street.
There was no squirting man.
It's been proven Pete.
Okay.
So let me circle around all the things you just said.
The first wording or not r Kelly,
one squirting is like the sexual chem trails.
That's what it is.
It's like the people that believe in it,
they won't let it go.
It's real.
Real.
Nope.
It's,
it's like scientists.
No,
it never existed until a few years ago.
All these years,
all these years,
women for all these years we're holding in their p and then someone told them
they don't have to anymore and they started just pinging all over.
Guys call on it.
Squirting the baby boomer.
Yeah,
I mean that's exactly what's going on.
It's kind of the same thing.
It's that Shit's funny though.
Yeah.
People do a lot of crazy shit for cameras.
I started becoming somewhat of a different person when I first started shooting
because the chat itself is like,
like a comedian,
right?
Like you get up there,
you get high after people's energy of like interacting right with you.
So while you're playing,
do you have a separate monitor that has the chairs,
two webcams to monitor their studio mic?
Like this one hanging above me.
A studio,
Mike,
while you're playing.
And like I said,
I have a high voice I need to like not pierce people's ears.
So you were saying that before the show,
you were saying your voice is so high that if you go,
what the fuck?
Yeah,
like any crazy freak people out.
So,
uh,
I dunno how we got to twitch,
but yeah,
twitch is huge.
They got bought by Amazon for $970 million.
What the fuck?
Amazon,
what are you doing with your money?
Yeah,
no,
it's because it's got,
so the League of legends finals last year had more viewership I think.
Then the Nhl Stanley Cup and the Roseville combined
what it's going to,
it's the,
it's the future Joe.
It's the added stuff.
Future and fuck.
And facing the add value is so overwhelmingly valuable is because the
interaction,
right?
Everyone's chatting,
they're,
they're talking directly to it.
When you're on a couch watching a TV.
Yeah.
It got this commercial is fucking dumb or oh,
cool.
Cerebral commercial on twitch.
You're like,
wow,
look at this fucking clown in the commercial.
Oh that's awesome.
Or that's a cool product or whatever you're typing,
right?
So the engagement is there.
The stats are there.
You literally,
I have on my channel,
I have one button,
I click and I have my demographic.
What countries watch me,
how many hours they watch.
I have all the stats on my page that I can export it to my sponsors or whoever
supports my page.
Whoa,
okay,
let's go to this fucking website.
We have to investigate every one of our past ones.
I do.
We do.
I'm with Kim all the time.
Watch some real players.
I want to see some real players,
no disrespect,
but I like to see guys actually know what the fuck they're doing.
When you were playing this and you're doing this,
like what's an average viewer?
Like how many,
how many viewers average do you get?
What of these?
I get like four to 5,000 concurrent at a time.
Four or 5,000 is normal.
He made it has pride.
I have a teammate who seems a lot more than me.
He gets like 10 to 15,000 okay,
let's watch your game.
What's wedge?
Counterstrike?
So this is all the different games that are available that you can watch.
You could actually watch poker and music now hold on a second.
But you can watch poker.
I had guys play poker from their home.
So you watch people play videos,
live video tournaments or yeah,
so when my buddy Griffin is actually huge at poker jaguars,
his name,
he used to be a pro cachet player.
He's up like 6 million in poker.
She gone click on one of these and let's see what the fuck goes on.
Like how many viewers are,
this guy's from Poland actually,
I might have been pulling away live right now.
He's 3000 Jesus Christ.
What's 27 million?
Well that one is overall viewership.
Fucking Christ.
And so this guy is,
this is counterstrike boy though.
The graphics are crude.
So it's,
yeah,
it's uh,
so that's an AK 47.
What?
Hold on.
Crack his volume of,
what is he saying?
This is to Polish teams.
He's speaking Polish.
This guy's actually Polish.
I've met him when I was in a turn and pull in.
Really the team on the right.
Virtus pro is like the best team in Poland.
They're playing gamers too for an online lease.
So I guess the graphics are not that important because this is,
it seems really dated older and kind of shakes like compared to the old version
of counterstrike.
This is like a big upgrade.
So that's been the thing that's actually kind of made it cool.
Is that because the obviously the crazy of the graphics and the physics doesn't,
the game play itself is less true.
Like you remember playing quake,
how'd that look?
Right.
Like if quake was super modernized,
I have a feeling that the integrity of the physics would,
we'd go down hill.
Yeah.
Well that was one of the things that people didn't like about the newer games to
the physics changed like quick to changed and then quick three became more like
quick to see.
Seeing the chat on the right.
Everyone's going nuts.
A lot of people like a,
a quick three rather became while a quick one because everyone was there
feedback quite too.
You did this.
I don't like it.
Go slower.
The thing about quick too is like the movement was slower but the graphics are
better.
But then quick three was like sorta the best.
Jamie do you find one of the hot chicks playing counter strike?
That's the new thing was the cam girls are now becoming gamer girls and so
that's what I've been training him condom to do and a couple other girls is to
play games and they went around running the movement.
Brian and there's all these,
there's all these girls are like we got to stop showing or Cleveland should be
taken seriously.
And I'm like no,
show your cleavage.
You'll make money.
Yes.
Now how is he ruining the movement then?
No,
I was joking cause like he was saying pull up on these cam girls.
I'm always up Jamie.
Okay.
She's cool.
She gets shit a lot.
This girl,
she's from Canada.
I haven't had the kitty plays so she gets shit a lot because she spends a lot of
time interacting and not playing.
So he was,
yeah cause she's sitting there chatting but she's an attention whore.
She's not,
no offense.
Right.
So I've met her.
She's a cool person.
She's likes attention.
She knows she probably makes,
I don't know what she makes.
This is me just bullshitting.
But she had me smokes 10 to 20 grand a month.
Yeah.
Hold the fuck on.
This girl makes 10 to 20 Glitz,
Glitz,
listen woods.
And she also said,
Jeremy,
just talk
to the chat is this saga
if anyone watching Joe Rogan streamer now can you go and kitties chat and say
something?
There it is.
I knew they would.
All right.
Play some fast cause if you guys want to play with me,
this is the best time to come play with me
so we can get a Joe Rogan spam in the chat.
Probably just by saying this.
I'm sure we can chat to you.
Such cute.
Anyway,
there it is powerful Joe Rogan.
So that's why it kind of gets addictive.
You see like I started streaming and people wouldn't be like,
so if you scroll down,
yeah I'll text on the page.
Can you scroll below her?
Oh Jamie.
Text her like you know her as a human being.
Could you scroll down and share?
Like wait,
it says you can tip.
So right.
Does she keep going down?
It'll say like donate somewhere can contribute.
So you the right there,
if you click contribute or make a donation,
any donation of $50 or more will pop up as a fan letter on the stream.
So what people do is they donate $100 to say,
hey kitty,
hope you have a great a day or $5 or $3 or do you have a minimum right?
Scroll back so we can see the chat,
the chat to go see Joe Rogan or going off.
Hey Jordan,
Joe Rogan.
See Evan's going off.
Joe,
I love this shit is killing.
Oh Paul Elysse can we see what she's saying?
And people can subscribe to you.
Kind of like,
you know,
uh,
and you can have like $5 a subscription and if you have like a shit load of
subscribers every month and just,
it can hear both of you guys at the same time.
Turn her off then so we can't hear it.
What are you saying?
So you can subscribe to channels,
right?
That's one of the things that you can do.
I like,
her subscription is $5 to subscribe to her channel and so every month that
subscription renews.
So she has like,
I mean subscription ten thousand ten thousand people or whatever.
That's what it's like a few thousand a month.
She makes $50,000 a month.
I mean not her was a split the sub with the website,
so some people get a better deal with a lot,
get 50 $52 it's just trying to figure out what's going on.
Yeah.
Could go back to her.
Okay.
Oh yeah,
let's get an olive garden spam going on.
Yeah.
You guys need to tell Katie to do the Flash Bang dance.
No,
I don't think he's looking at,
tell him Jordan says to you the Flash Bang,
dance it to camera with him.
So me and her had a dance off one land,
so I'm going to try to get her to do this dance.
I can't do it.
Don't mister red pen.
Why am I on it?
Nope.
Another,
I swear to God,
you're going to get a strongly worded message from me on Twitter.
You're going to get a strongly worded message.
Who's going to get a strongly worded message?
Me Or you?
Hi.
I guess,
no,
she's fine.
We're just tell it did explain to this lovely young lady that we're just trying
to figure things out.
What does that,
we can see that.
All right,
let's let's leave her and go to someone that's actually playing a game.
No offense young lady.
But it's really cool how that is.
That's fascinating in what's interesting is that a lot of people like uh,
are using your x boxes like
to watch Netflix and stuff like that and twitches now on as Xboxes playstations
it's on a Roku now.
So people are watching it as TV.
I'll go home at the end of the night,
not turn on NBC or ABC.
I'll just watch somebody play counterstrike Paul Asleep.
Cause it's,
it's,
I like watching video games.
And one of the cool things is that you to have coaches now like in,
in these professional things.
And these are good guys that like to watch video games.
Who's funny?
Which I set up pop and makes yeah,
this guy.
So he's kind of like a,
he's just not competitive at all.
He just jokes around.
But he makes so much money.
And what is he playing?
What cameras right now?
So war the war,
that's,
this is the game that Dunkin had a throwaway three different times.
He had to delete it.
He broke it.
He,
he like took the discs and snap them in half and then went out and bought new
ones.
I'm done man.
Click.
So she,
there's three different ways these people make money,
right?
There's the sub service.
This is what she scraped Shin,
right.
Ad Revenue.
So he's got 18,000 years.
He probably makes like a hundred bucks an hour on that.
And then he has donations or whatever.
So this guy in particular had a couple of crazy fans from the Middle East,
like prince dudes that gave him like 50 grand each.
35 grand.
I had one guy from Abu Dhabi give me 10 grand one time on my work just to yeah,
exactly right.
And we had a private,
my free cams.com/jordan right now.
No.
Uh,
he literally was just like,
he liked the counterstrike scene.
He gave,
he gave a Polish counter player 30 grand.
He gave one of my teammates 20 grand now that you only got yeah,
I was told.
Okay.
Sounds like Yo,
what the fuck?
It's a fun dude.
When someone gives you that money though,
you don't really know what to say.
Right.
So it just took time for you to get back into quick joke.
No,
it's definitely not heard about.
The addictive
was yeah,
I've,
I've uh,
I have addiction issues of,
of avoided him with drugs for the most part,
although some would disagree,
but uh,
I,
I do have them hardcore with games to the point where I avoid games.
But watching this is,
this is a totally different now because these guys are making the money.
I can't believe you have a subscription link there and you click on that and you
can give this cat five bucks a month.
She had out to soda pop in.
I fill out of home,
he's got 93 million fucking views on his channel and t 18,000 people watching
right now.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
I was actually teaching a kid who,
he's only 10 years old,
I'm friends with uh,
your friends with 10 year olds.
But uh,
he,
he questionable.
He wants the same age.
Mentally he wants to grow up to be you.
Like that's what he wants to do.
So,
so I was teaching him how to be a twitch host and uh,
me and Jamie will play grand theft auto with him and he would practice,
you know,
talking and stuff like that.
And it's amazing that this is now a job.
That kid pulled us up,
pulled us up on,
there was an image she pulled up on the screen to show that you did a scene with
David spade.
I washed out.
What was it called?
Just shoot me.
Yeah,
I did an episode of that.
I watched
this episode.
This is hilarious.
Hey fellow,
this is good for this guy though.
So he's making money and he's gonna have to show his tips.
He said what's going on?
Well,
who is pissed?
Someone else pulling that up in front of him.
It's him.
It's him doing,
let's just do this all day and go people,
it's roommate to freak him out.
Um,
so this guy right now is playing this game.
Give us a volume so I can hear how this is going on.
He's not talking.
Okay.
Saying let's do it.
So this game you can kind of like lounge.
Loved it.
That's where I know him from
Washington when I was like 1215 now.
So he asked for more.
Okay,
so this guy is playing these games and he just talking I guess.
And that's why people like him
had Phil Defranco and Youtube.
So like people follow someone and they like right now I'm doing this podcast,
people enjoyed it.
This here behind the story.
So for him sometimes he'll sit there.
He does every Saturday night he does a 24 hour stream all day.
He plays 24 hours.
He probably does prior and after.
I would say that's stamina.
Was anybody ever jerked off on screen?
If they do get off of twitch,
you'd yes and yes.
You got in trouble at times I was playing grand theft auto when a girl came over
and she just started taking off her top and stuff like that and I forgot that it
was twitching because on Xbox live you can be twitching and you totally forget
it's on and then you fall asleep and wake up the next day and your camera's
still on.
Oh,
people who are watching you sleep like creepers.
Yeah.
I've done a few times.
Awesome.
Bruce,
but I play different way.
I just go in grand theft auto,
kill hookers and try to take pictures of their underwear.
Have you seen the fucking complaints that people said that the,
there's a hack in grand theft auto where you could verbally rape some or you
could v virtually rape someone.
You haven't seen that with their body freezes.
They can't do anything and get behind them and you start pumping them.
But people like really upset like you know this girl was talking about how she
felt completely violated because her character was trapped and some guy was
like,
isn't that a game where they're allowed to kill you with a fucking crowbar?
Like that doesn't freak you out.
But it did mention it.
Yeah,
but it's normal.
The sack side.
But the cocaine that I'm selling to buy this car is cool.
Alright,
so how many people are on this twitch thing in any given moment?
Go back to that.
Let's see what like what's the overall they have like more internet traffic then
like most websites like and like they accounted for some huge number.
I'm sure you could look it up of streaming.
Like it's like them youtube and like Netflix.
God Damn,
I'm so out of the loop with the shit now the,
I want to see what it's like when you're watching people play poker.
Yeah.
So they normally have like six tables and it's really down.
There's poker right there.
Yeah.
So you go to poker and so these guys are just playing video poker.
So turning to have like a little art click on that car right there.
I don't understand thousand or 4,000 viewers on this.
Quite a bit less.
So quite a bit less people are playing,
he has a million views but quite a bit less than the video games.
So way more people or want to watch people.
Well this is a game.
Here's the website,
right?
So a lot of people get residual fuse cause people are just looking around for a
Gamer.
Right.
Not a lot of people are just casually looking around for poker player.
Now do you think you could play pool on something like this?
Like digital,
like no actual pool.
Uh,
could you have a remote camera camera set up where you can play actual pool?
I don't know their rules.
Like if you're a channel who already does other things and then one day he just
had to have a Friday night is pool night.
I think you could,
I think.
I think you can totally do it.
You'd have to talk to them.
Probably talked to him.
I don't want you to like say I'm playing counterstrike and then you're playing
pool seven days a week obviously.
Right?
Yeah.
You wouldn't want to get flashing.
Dan called me an n word.
How the area,
obviously that's the one I've concentrated on.
I know that you got right to it.
So this guy's playing for different games at a time.
A lot of those video game poker dude's the real ace as they do that right from
program to keep track of the hands everyone's been playing like on their tables
and stuff.
You pay for it because these guys are playing,
they're making good money now.
Played Poker for tables a day.
Right.
And he's so this cat or at a time,
uh,
his playing,
he's playing for different games at the same time where he's making money on
these games are losing money.
Gambling,
gambling.
Yeah.
Now is that legal again?
Like how's that work now?
Cause I know poker like they were for a while.
You could play it out of Vegas,
but you got to play people in Vegas online.
I think it's something to do.
I was like Canada.
Okay,
so this guy wrote it pokers new to twitch,
but it's growing rapidly with some poker celebrities.
Daniel knew Grano [inaudible] who's been streaming?
Jason Summerville.
Oh,
okay.
So it's a new thing.
Some new additional outside of music recently,
like Dj Steve Aoki,
he plays video.
You put a Gopro up on stage and then he does his set at a club and streams it
from twitch.
Kevin does it,
but that's not a video game.
Music.
Oh,
I feel like this.
I thought people would be stoked to have you on twitch as a pod.
I can totally connect you with those people too from dude,
we'll do it.
Yeah,
why not?
I mean we do use treme.
I'm saying he,
I know there's new,
what did you say?
You got the new tri caster.
You could be like,
could we do use tree men twitch at the same time?
Oh yes we can folks.
All right,
we'll do it.
Yeah,
I'll totally killed those people.
Interesting.
Uh,
Kevin pair has a stage at his new studio and he will have like concerts and
he'll be playing the drums
and stuff on twitch now and shit.
How many people are wanting a lot?
Kevin has a full studio where he does at gaming.
Uh,
and on one he does podcasts.
How many people watch when he's like,
I haven't watched it.
I just,
he's just telling me about it.
Okay,
let's see some other,
uh,
video games.
See what else we got here.
This is fascinating man.
This is a completely new world to me.
Jamie.
We show him call of duty.
So this is kind of professional
but not really professional retainer.
Right?
But you,
you're playing and you're making money.
Like I'm a part time streamer cause I still compete.
She,
I think the genius of this is the whole donation thing.
The genius of this is getting people to donate and the,
the fact that these guys can,
so how else can they make money?
They can make money by subscriptions.
Subscriptions.
That's like you could run your salary if you have 2000 subs consistently and it
fluctuated.
It's always four 99 well,
some people negotiate,
I think it to six,
but you split that.
So like the average person gets 50% I get 70% of the top people get like 90%
like there's guys that have a shitload of subs and they play all day.
Wow.
So they,
they get 90% so this guy named lyric or I $4 out of the five at 80% and uh,
um,
he has like around 10,000 subs as of last month.
So that's automatically 40 grand a month.
He's making Jesus.
Yes.
From his subs and then donations.
That's a half a million dollars a year.
Oh yeah.
He makes,
he owed her a half a million dollars credible that has it.
And he's doing that all on t on twitch while getting his bachelor's in computer
science.
That's amazing.
Fast has graduated.
Congratulations Dude.
Fuck yeah.
So that guy doesn't even have to be the best of the best.
No,
that's,
and that's the thing is the entertainment value.
Yeah.
One around interactive numbers.
81 million people have watched him.
He's not even on right now in this people in this chat room.
Oh my God.
81 million because fucking credible.
Yeah.
Your chat becomes like a community home for people.
So they literally will hang out in there.
See,
and you could like,
you have all these little emotive con,
see how it's got like a little cat face,
that's his icon.
You can paste all sorts of dumb little things and it comes like a fun way for
people to,
there'll be in someone else's chat and they'll spam my emo TACAN like
nothing.
That's fucking incredible.
Uh,
now,
no,
I'm really intrigued.
It's interesting because they really took the formula from porn,
you know,
porn noise starts off first in the always invented first and then they moved it
into like having their donations and the chat room and all that stuff.
My Free Cams.
But the hot girl thing is huge.
So that's why I've been trying to get all the girls on here to do it.
Uh,
playing video games in the mouth,
Bro.
I like it.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a career now.
Like these girls,
like especially at porn stars when they get to an end of their porn star life,
they're like,
what am I going to do now?
I have no job.
Start playing Mario brothers.
I'm sure you can fucking make
diction.
So let's go to another one.
Jamie was interesting.
This lyric guy.
I like that.
I love what he's doing.
So how did that get so big?
Why is he so big?
Um,
some of it's a domino snowball.
Killer player.
Yeah.
He plays all sorts of games.
He's got a radio voice.
So let me see before you did,
I'm sorry to interrupt.
Go down.
I want to see what other games are available.
But this is grand theft.
So he's got a radio voice.
Oh,
I'm just the lear.
He actually doesn't even have a Webcam.
It blows my mind how popular is without even a camera.
It's a,
nobody knows what he looks like.
Well they do,
cause he's shown up at a couple of conventions.
Oh.
So they take pictures and we know him.
They know him.
That exactly shows up with a fucking,
one of those guy Fawkes masks.
Um,
let's see,
scroll down.
Call of duty poker called,
what is h one z one that was made by Sony.
It's like a survival Zombie.
Like it's like a shitty version of grand theft auto.
You run around like a mass world.
Okay.
Is this a game?
I'd never heard of.
How many people are watching this cat when he's playing?
He's a new partner and 1000 yen,
which is pretty good for like an average person and you're going to be able to
turn that into like a moderate small day job and not have to and he's got
277,000 instead of working at Starbucks here,
a low level twitch streamers,
right?
Yeah.
So okay.
This guy's probably making a couple grand a month,
maybe a thousand bucks a month.
He's got a subscriber button.
So yeah,
maybe if he's working hard at me.
So maybe a plate pays for his rent.
There you go.
Yeah.
Wow.
And so this is a weird game where it's a third person thing and you're running
around,
you're fighting zombies and he's okay,
this is a stupid game.
Bull ring.
All right.
What else can I scroll down but I want,
I want to see what games are available.
Not just grand theft auto games available every day of quake on here.
Yeah.
Let me see that.
I go to that.
You could pretty much play at any single game.
People the off.
Hello Jesus.
If people are playing,
the game would be here quick.
I love,
I could,
I should text my quake friends in it.
It's a dead game,
Huh?
Yeah,
but I love watching quick.
I went to QuakeCon a couple of times in Texas.
Oh,
it's incredible.
Halflife still available,
Huh?
No,
it keeps growing.
Let's see it as a type quake in the top left and see if that pops up.
A lot of weird games that never even heard of.
I mean how does someone even create a new game now when these people get so
addicted to the chess?
Chess is video chats.
Is that what it is?
Like how chest is like a wizard?
Everyone else's like a young kid.
Remember Chattel chest,
chest,
where it was the box where they,
where they would,
they were like fighter.
It was like a game that was for like early computers and it was chess,
but the guys weren't be nights and it would be animated and they would like cut
the other person in house rather than hot
tea.
Oh yeah.
Technology all over the place playing quake life.
Can you watch the video team?
Deathmatch
Jean Stream Jean.
So is that what this is?
We're going to watch a stream.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yup.
That's it.
See you like this.
The of graphics are quite a bit better in this than they are the counter strike.
But even this is old.
This is quick three
dude.
I love this shit though.
My favorite term is to watch back when we were like the painkiller quake.
Unreal tournament.
Well what's interesting to me,
you know these games they,
it seems like you get hooked on one and that one game becomes your shit,
but then you run the risk of being left behind because the new games come out.
So I think the more legitimate thing each sports gets,
obviously there's more interest for the game developers to keep their game
lasting.
Right.
Whereas in the past it was like by the new game,
how are we going to make money?
We need to come out with a new game.
So people buy it.
But now there's way more ways for them to make money.
So in counterstrike,
you could change the way your AK 47 links.
Now you can put a blue dragon decal on it and you pay the $5 should I d
calories,
$30 or $2 right?
Depending on how rare the decal is.
And that is used to crowd fund for them to make money and for us to have
tournaments.
So valve now the creators,
the counterstrike hosts a quarter million dollar tournament like every couple of
months from the money they get from the micro economy they created for
counterstrike.
This is insane.
That's why legal legends was
big.
Right now they sell these trinkets and garbs and things for your character and
they make like $50 million a month or whatever.
The world of video.
Don't call me on that.
But I,
I,
I get your point.
The world of video games is so,
it's so interesting.
So alien to me,
but I had no idea it was this deep and involved.
It's grown a lot with websites like twitch really combined.
How many of them are there besides twitch?
That no,
twitch dominates that realm.
There's like hit box,
Mlg TV majorly gave me TV.
Uh,
Zubu TV.
There's a couple,
but no one's really has the reach that to a chess.
Somebody just said that Kevin Prayer is twitching right now.
We're playing a video game.
Okay.
Go to Kevin for,
he's twitch.tv/the attack.
Yeah.
See if this works.
Okay.
Let's see.
Not a hero and other stuff with Alex.
This is Kevin.
Yep.
This cabin right now.
Yeah.
Crank up the volume.
Okay,
Bro.
Bro,
who's Kevin?
I'm sorry.
I don't know.
This.
Kevin Pereira was the host of attack of the show.
Uh,
g four network daily objective.
He's asking,
he's a very bright man.
Enter.
Why didn't as beautiful complexion and excellent bone structure looking that
jawline boom happening.
What's your nonexempt team?
That's the one cop.
Did they dispatch a shot?
That dude in the face so much.
Oh no,
he's got a partner.
Oh,
he's only got a couple hundred viewers had shot my blogs.
You don't let them use that on yet.
Sorry Bud.
He only has a couple of a hundred viewers cause he just got on right now.
Kevin.
Oh they're saying Joe's watching now.
Hi Kevin.
Hi Joe.
Say Hi fellow Brian redbeds and we should go back to history and uh,
and that was it.
C nine pro Gamer guy knows Gamer guy.
What a weird world we live in that respect to the CS go communities funny.
We loved that.
Hello cancer that go around it.
So is that Kevin's studio that we're looking at in the corner?
Yeah,
this is cave.
This is one part of his studio.
This is where he does all his twitch gaming and stuff in his podcast.
And now the first thing you think of it in all these rooms,
just like where did they rub one out?
Like what part of the room?
He's going to have the script on us.
You motherfucker.
Oh Shit.
Screen on Rogan.
All right,
how can we do this?
Let's enter the Matrix.
We can somehow,
there's a lag though.
Unfortunately.
It's probably like seven to 10 seconds.
Looking at it as an open the floodgate of racist
racist stuff.
It's always racist stuff for some reason.
How do you sub domain?
I subscribers left.
There we go.
Oh,
not logged in then.
Joe Rogan won't see the studio.
I want to see your studio.
The studio.
Oh,
how cool.
This is getting way confusing.
This is so bizarre.
This is like two mirrors facing each other.
Ooh,
Nice.
Sharat your shirt sir.
And get that a tall Kevin Pereira with the dope studio.
Let me go full screen.
Go full screen on the Cam.
Look at that.
Hey Kevin,
we're finally getting to hear you now.
Oh this is dope
podcast table.
Oh Nice.
Alex the band room.
But I don't even know how we get up to ban the room.
Alright.
Sprint.
This is a place he's renting.
They need like a USB extension cord.
Walk me.
Look at this.
This is hilarious.
Boy,
this is so bizarre watching Kevin.
So we're watching Kevin Pereira and it's the attack on,
on twitch.
We'll get it gone.
They see you're hearing too far in Los flicks,
Bro.
Is Fuck today backward.
That was brought out.
Wow.
This is very strange
Joe.
Just wait,
I'm going to give you the,
wow,
this is interesting.
Oh,
so he's freaking me out.
Now we've got the
bar
watching US watching them.
This is fucking range.
I think we can time travel somehow.
I think we just did.
Look what we're doing here.
We're showing his dick again back to his tablet.
Joe's got a full head of hair.
What's good?
This is all so bizarre.
It's like a mailbox or whatever that movie was my voice.
She's got deeper.
So this is Kevin's studio and he plays video games out of here as well.
Yeah.
This is his twitch room in his podcast room on this side.
And then on the other side,
Yaz.
Oh Jesus got word.
Oh,
let's see which one is real now I don't even know what twins.
Wow.
The one on the lower right hand corner is real time.
The one on the left is like what he's getting from us on Ustream.
So the left one is the use treme one cause it's a delay.
And the one on the lower right is real time.
Wow.
This is crazy.
He's got a sweet setup man.
Yeah.
Again,
he's going to show his dick pics.
It's the same thing though,
over and over again.
Now this is like the,
why is the three different levels in the bottom?
I don't know.
So does he have a bunch of employees or something?
Oh yeah,
he's got,
he's got a full staff over there.
I mean they have been the one receptionist there.
They play video games and live the life.
But why is it,
why does he have a reception?
What's the receptionist?
Therefore,
uh,
just to play video games and stuff like that.
So,
so here's,
here's,
here's one.
Here's second room.
So this is where he plays pinball and whose ball?
It's a bunch of couches.
It's also has a humongous green screen on the side.
Here's this kitchen area,
which is like a bar in the middle.
Here's this bar here.
You can just turn it up.
People like,
Oh yeah.
So this is always a pool table like this.
Wow,
this is the best room.
Right.
Well,
okay,
this is really fascinating.
Oh Kevin,
that's a whole recordings get hit to set up.
He's not messing around 30 sessions and whatnot.
Oh my God.
His placements to be huge and these walls are Joe rolled out because we have
issues and then Loungy sorta hang out area,
but we can also unlatch the big barn doors here and push 'em out.
They just push out and we have room for like 150 people.
So he has shows there.
Yeah.
He has live shows,
concerts and stuff.
Invites his friends and Fam Dicks we can die.
Wow.
This is crazy.
Kevin Pereira has taken it to the next level by himself.
Wow.
So he has all these people that work for him.
Like tell us how generating revenue twitch baby,
really switch podcasting.
All of the sudden some other shows they do and some production to do for other
companies.
They have a whole production company.
Haven't done my podcast.
Yeah.
Okay.
In the studio.
We'll hang out and whatnot.
Okay.
All right.
Well tell Kevin I said thanks pretty dope.
Wow,
this is amazing.
He's got like 10 fucking people working for them.
The,
this is so strange.
Kevin took it to the next level.
That's pretty bad ass.
Yeah.
He took what we did and went like five steps beyond one's step beyond.
That's the problem guys.
Uh,
when you start showing where you live.
Yeah.
It's the one other side of things.
We've had bad experiences at that.
What have you had like swatting?
Oh,
I fucking hate them.
Swatting is known as a pretty funny video of actually on youtube of them
cleaning my room with like,
oh,
so you,
that actually happened with you?
That was you or oh,
right.
So while you were playing a game,
someone called the Swat team on the fuck.
I started kids,
people ordering the pizzas
at first and like shit and not paying for it.
Right.
So they wouldn't pay for them.
I get my speeches,
sorry guys,
here's a couple of bucks.
You wasted your time.
Can I have that pizza?
They would leave firetruck.
Stan would next like,
oh,
they said your house is burning down.
Obviously it's not
like a month later.
I'm just chilling and this is so,
yeah,
I'm in my room right here.
I see my dad out in front of walk down the street.
I was like,
I started an alarm but it's not loud now.
So what's going on?
I said guys,
I'll be right back.
I was playing the game and uh,
this is like 10 20 minutes later.
Oh my God.
So there's a pretty funny edited version.
I don't know if this is the one.
So they don't know right now that this isn't real.
I even told them,
cause they were about to come in with the canine unit,
I was like,
yeah,
there's a couple of cats in there.
Can you just chill in the canine units?
They,
we're looking for dead bodies.
We can adhere to like what you want.
I was like,
guys,
you're getting pranked her now.
Like look me up on Youtube while you guys are storming the house.
Like you're getting pranked.
Like I have no data to tell them that they're getting some calls.
Christ,
they're coming in with fucking guns.
And they had me and my dad in handcuffs on the end of the day.
So,
so someone called and said I had murdered my neighbor and had someone else
hostage and they call it through like a proxy DNS or whatever and or you know,
uh,
what did they call it?
A VPN.
So you can't trace where they call from.
So did you give out your fun or did someone,
someone uh,
they,
I guess my,
someone found my Skype username and then traced the log for all the calls that
are,
where are they cause most frequently from.
And if they just like triangulated my house Ip address and then they did
something called doxxing where they get everything about my house and my
personal info.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
that's a real issue,
right,
with the swatting,
I've seen that on TV a bunch of times.
It was like real celebrities that I supposedly,
he's like a big issue because it happens all the time.
Little things like this word for me also I had to do is after I just talked to
the police chief,
I was like,
guys,
this happened a couple of times,
like please don't respond like this again.
Like here's my number.
Right,
but then what if somebody wants a murder you?
So what they do is they said they have to send one guy
every time,
but someone could just do this all day long.
So they put a little asterisk,
they said near my house address and they have a message for their crew.
It's a little protocol now.
Wow.
That'd be scary as fuck man.
Okay,
let's get out of this.
That'd be scary as fuck.
Yeah.
Well to be honest,
I actually knew what was happening right away cause it wasn't scary.
So my dad was kind of your mouth,
but I walked out to see what's going on.
And Ray went out with my friend door.
I as you saw something like a tank top and shorts and if you had a dog they
could've shot.
That's,
and I've talked about that to France.
I would have been so fucking furious if any animal of mine was killed.
But luckily my rattle,
everybody,
no,
no dogs.
They're my rattle.
I wasn't there,
but that's not normal.
It's a lot of times people over the dog inside the house,
they come inside,
they'll just shoot your dog.
Yeah.
And they'll kick down the door.
So like I said,
luckily they,
they were at the end of the block when I walked out and I looked and I see all
these guys went in bushes and tree lines and 16 is point at me.
I was like,
Oh fuck.
Douchebags God damn man,
I don't give shit.
Walked down the center
of the street.
I'm like,
cool,
I'm doing it.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
But yeah,
that's the worry is like,
what if no one is home?
I'm home alone.
I have my dog,
I'm chilling in my apartment and they come up and fucking blow my window and
kicked down the door.
They see me like they,
maybe they see my expression like surprised or angry cause I just died in the
game.
Or I say,
hey,
bombed down,
buttoned down.
And,
and then they're at the,
they're at the door behind me while I'm communicating that to my teammates.
They busted in the door and fucking club me over the head or something.
How often does this happen?
So there is another video actually someone online who got more surprised where
he realized he,
he's being funny.
It's like,
Oh shit,
people are carrying my house.
I think I'm getting swatted.
And they kind of like do that.
I've seen a few of them now.
There's no way to get stomped on.
I mean how could they stop that right now with current technology?
Well like I said,
it only wants,
it's happened at that address they have,
they have a protocol then about don't have one of the kids who put supposedly
did it to me,
he got caught and they caught him cause he did 18 different swatting from Vegas
in 19 year old kid from Vegas he sends to five years.
Oh my God.
He's doing jail time cause he's 19 Oh my God.
It's the same type of kids who do those denial of service attacks.
It's a big problem.
Gaming,
you know the DDOSS Oh we made they flood your Internet.
They can do if they drive here and I'm sure junk had it before.
It's like I try to picture of the person that like what kind of like gang
initiation of nerds and they're all like circle jerk and in like some kind of
like tech lab.
Does Haldir fury deed or no,
I got to stock Candyman Candyman it's like talking about fortune to stop and
change the topic.
Let's talk about 14 what's your favorite flavor?
Pieces of fast?
Many to me that we're in this weird world where all this stuff is kind of going
on at the same time like the DNA,
the interaction of this twitch stuff.
Go back to the twitch website again.
I find this the most fascinating because this seems to me to be almost better
than professional gaming,
like being good at it.
It seems like what you need to do is be like that lyric guy and just be kind of
entertaining.
What does that guy skill level.
He's like really good.
Keep scrolling down.
We see with other games,
the decision between being a streamer and a pro Gamer is mostly pride,
right?
Like you compete and you want to win and considered good at something and you
what's created and you travel around a lot.
What's that?
What's creative?
Creative.
Oh,
drawing.
Drawing.
Come on.
Their video games is someone drawing people drawing and go there.
Let's see.
This mind occupied.
How many people are watching this guy draw 30 people who's got 59 was the game
development one.
Two people watching people.
This actually got it guys.
A talented artist.
Yeah.
So you get to watch him draw.
And is he drawing in Photoshop?
Is that what's going on or is it taking close to it?
Hmm,
like the popularity of periscope is based on the same formula.
Also everyone having their own TV shows.
Subscribing do is feed back chat rooms.
All this stuff is the future.
Now he's doing this with a Wycombe like one of those tablets drawn pretty calm.
You can just broadcast anything from your computer almost.
It's just a matter of if they're going to allow you to put it on their service
is bullshit.
Let's storm this cause chat 28 people we have on blow up.
They haven't heard us yet.
There it goes.
Bam.
It takes like 15 seconds there.
It keeps your whole day.
Your whole chats on you might have 500 in there,
but it won't refresh yet.
Asked for permission before posting a link.
Purge.
Oh my God.
Racism again.
But that's how he didn't say the n word because he uses the number one instead
of an eye.
So it's okay.
Yeah,
you have to do the filter.
Wow.
This is,
this n word thing is rude.
I can someone please call me a spic or maybe even a chink in the game.
Just a tired of the n word.
That's one thing that's weird about the gaming community with like Xbox live or
online chat or anything.
It's just racist and like there's no,
there's no like everyone's a racist on Xbox live.
So the,
because it's forbidden right now.
Let me ask you this,
so what was your take on this whole Gamergate thing?
Did that affect you at all?
Or You were like,
what are you nerds fighting over?
And for folks who don't know what Gamer Gate was,
you know it's,
I kinda started out as some sort of a fight over online journalism and became
some thing about feminism and social justice warriors and all kinds of
craziness.
Yeah.
That was honestly,
I don't even know the whole story I heard,
I only heard about it partially because people were talking about the female
side of things.
And I remember a lot of the companies I worked with immediately I started
changing the direction of marketing.
They're like put females and all of our adverts like Kaylee cause they want it
to be like we supported female gamers.
Whoa,
whoa.
Really?
Yeah.
So patronizing.
I don't need this taste fishy with companies but I saw a lot of these east
sports companies like instead of having a guy wearing the gaming headset,
it wasn't a girl now like by the way,
like we do like gamers or girl gamers rather.
So,
so their response to it was to said they're supportive of female gaming,
supporting girls streamers.
On tuition.
It's the whole thing was just so bizarre because it all happened at a one gow
was banging some dude who was a story.
I never really know.
It's legendary.
It's like the story of Jesus.
It's like a bunch of different versions of it,
you know,
all the way back to Thor to fill think.
It's very strange.
It's very strange when you have these,
these little satellite communities and they branch off and they,
they do battle with each other.
Yeah.
I tried to watch one of those two minute videos that explained to everything and
I couldn't even figure it out.
I've tried,
I couldn't,
I just couldn't tolerate it.
It was just so nonsensical.
But uh,
it was like a lot of it just seemed like,
you know,
it seemed like there was a lot of bullshit on both sides,
you know.
So you didn't even pay attention like the hardcore gamers,
like you're like so insulated,
deepen the hive that you didn't even hear the rumbling outside my manager's,
yeah,
exactly.
My managers from like the,
I play on a team called cloud nine.
They were talking about it cause it was like their sponsors discussed with them
about what it was.
But I didn't hear about it until after it's happened.
I was like,
wait,
what was this thing?
Oh well we try and say Jamie.
Okay,
strong went offline.
What?
Everyone in the chat made him go off line base.
Oh he's angry.
His mind's no longer occupied.
No,
it's 319 people watching though.
I killed the stream.
There's a,
there's a cool video on youtube.
I don't know Jamie,
I can send you this video.
Somebody just sent me of somebody getting robbed while twitching.
So there are twitching.
And then in the background you see him getting robbed?
Like someone's stealing things from their house.
Yeah.
Here Jamie.
That girl right?
I just sent it.
So they're playing and behind them people are stealing things.
Yeah.
It's a girl.
Pretty cute girl.
Looks like she doesn't even know
you.
Stuff like that.
How many people are faking things like that?
Just to get people to watch them.
Okay.
So we're kind of getting off track here.
Um,
so just twitch thing seems like a viable source of revenue obviously cause real.
But if you bank on that sort of same thing as like your dad was saying like this
is a volatile industry that you're entering into.
The one thing I will give people who go big on twitch that ways as you see like
lyric,
he doesn't necessarily have a marriage to one game.
So when a new game comes out is falling,
it's just like fuck it,
go play that game and we'll be entertained.
So that's the benefit.
And that's why I have dabbled in streaming.
I'm not a full time streamer but I could pay my bills with streaming and I go on
there and I tried to stream when I don't have to like a big chunk.
You could pay your bills with streaming.
Wow.
That is fucking crazy.
So you could just for a goof you could say,
oh you know like some people have like a little side job like that.
Your side job could be streaming and that could like pay for your rent.
Yeah,
definitely.
And the cool thing is obviously it's your own hours.
Just being an Uber driver or something.
Exactly.
But way more money than a new Uber driver will.
And the tips drivers don't get donation.
Yeah,
you don't get 10 grand from some dudes and two by.
Exactly.
Wow.
That is amazing that this is a world that I just was not aware of and so girls
do it and they do it because like hot girls can do it and they don't even have
to be good at games.
But there's all that,
there's a lot of girls who like,
cause there's not a lot of girl pro gamers like counter shake.
Like I don't know,
the answer lives is always a discussion of why aren't there more girls at the
top because they're out there looking for Dick.
That's why the side,
yeah and we're looking for girls.
You could argue that the guys aren't looking for girls right?
That well they are but they've given up.
I mean they are,
but they're like let's be realistic.
Games are here and they're fun.
So you have the girls that on on the stream that tried to like not portray that
sexiness because they want to be taken more seriously.
Sorry,
purpose.
I have a Hoodie on and there's,
yeah,
there's a lot of that right.
And I don't,
it's one thing like I understand that there's this one girl,
her name is Casey Tron and she makes fun of the whole thing.
She's got big boobs as it is,
but she pushes him up,
has the camera like angled in on it and she constantly says stupid shit and like
make like sexual innuendos all the time and like just different joke on the
stream because she wants to embrace the chaos that is the twitch chat and just
kind of,
and how to then,
what kind of like numbers does she get?
I mean she definitely,
it's definitely a full time job for you can make money.
Wow.
So could,
you could actually
make what a lawyer makes or a doctor makes a quarter million dollars.
Yeah,
that so crazy.
I,
I don't know why this is so surprising to me.
The TV networks are shitting their pants because of things like this twitch,
because the net,
you know,
more people are watching video games now than they are watching TV.
Is that true?
Yeah.
Really.
But there's a lot of channels,
man,
that's 250 channels just on direct TV or something like that.
More than that probably right.
Yeah.
But most of these games,
like they're getting way more viewers per day than an episode of Grey's anatomy
nowadays.
I saw this thing about the ultimate fighter,
you know,
uh,
the UFC show the reality show where someone who was saying that the,
I don't know if that's true,
but the ultimate fighter only had 246,000 people watch,
uh,
one of the episodes,
which is just,
I mean,
that's way less than we get for our podcast.
That's normal.
That's normal nowadays.
That's normal for twitch.
What are you saying?
It's normal nowadays for the low numbers on TV,
on cable,
but it's not because that,
that's like way lower than what it's been before.
Like as an example,
there's a show that's on one of these like oxygen networks or something like
that at a 10:00 PM on a on a Tuesday.
What would you think that numbers are for that 10:00 PM on a Tuesday on an
oxygen network show know how will they even configure that out,
man,
can you figure that out?
You can more so nowadays I think then you used to be able to,
because nowadays those numbers of the cable companies are sold to,
yeah,
that data is all,
that's all data.
Right,
but that's the,
the question is how do they know like it used to be obviously,
right?
I don't know.
It used to be Nielsen ratings.
It used to be you have to have a Nielsen box on your television.
That's the old school.
Yeah.
And then I think they still use that though.
My,
I don't think they're,
they know when people watch the Dvr show with the 24 hours,
like that's added into a DVR show.
They have to be monitoring your DVR box to know if you have,
watch my DVR though.
But that is,
is that watching it live?
It,
can they figure that out as well.
Live number four hours,
but they don't add that into the ratings.
Like if you watch television ratings that's not including the ratings.
Like if you see like um Big Bang theory.
If that's the number one show they don't factor in direct TV.
I don't believe they do.
I think it just depends on which day you're looking at it.
They might wait two more days and they'll give you the updated facts with
which I imagine all these channels have access to that.
That was the debate.
The debate though and television was whether or not to include the direct TV
numbers cause directv numbers were different than the numbers that they were
getting off of regular television.
As many people watching the television together.
Is there five people watching one screen?
You got to talk right into that dude I asked closer.
Is there,
is there five people watching one screen?
Right.
That's like the,
that's obviously the area on a computer you have to fill it in and you make a
twitch account
which makes it that much more valuable.
All the info is like age based.
They know how old.
Okay,
here it goes.
Netflix.
Netflix won't share it.
They won't tell you.
They don't need to tell you.
They're like fuck you.
We're Netflix shit internally.
They obviously have,
well they have 70 million people on Netflix now paying seven bucks a month.
Mother fucker.
Mother fuckers.
I think it's the 70 million.
Well Jamie,
you can find like Hulu seven off this year that either.
No,
I think they do.
Yeah.
How many people are on Netflix?
Um,
so how many people were watching house of cards do?
No,
they don't even tell you.
Hmm.
They don't know.
Find out how many people are on Netflix.
I think it's 70 million puzzle.
Yeah.
This ultimate fighter episode four of last week's ultimate fighter only did
286,000 views.
Hmm.
Yeah.
That's like a big key.
That's like a counterstrike tournament nowadays.
Cause that really kind of struck tournament.
That's what you would get.
Well the last major we had over a million concurrent fucking Christ.
1 million watching at the same time.
My God.
Yeah,
that's,
I'm in league of legends in those ones are monsters too because they have weekly
events this size that is unbelievable man.
We are living in strange,
strange times.
40 million domestic subscribers,
40 million domestic.
But worldwide I think worldwide they said it was 70 and I'm looking at a Forbes
article with it.
Hmm.
But even that 40 million domestic at seven bucks a month,
who,
who it
was,
they got cash paying me.
So the one side twitch ads or the one downside to twitch ads is that adblock
right?
Not Chrome.
So like some ads don't get shown,
so that doesn't go towards the counts per millennia.
The CPM or whatever that rate you get per thousand viewers.
So obviously on a TV show,
a TV box,
you can't turn off the commercial.
You could switch the channel.
But online you could literally like disable the ad so that you're always
watching the streamer because I could run an ad every eight minutes.
Some people don't want to see the ad,
they just went and watched Jordan.
So I,
when I ran a commercial,
I tried to make an effort to like leave the room so people aren't encouraged to
turn off ad block.
So there's nothing going on during my commercial.
So years commercials are scheduled.
No,
eight minutes.
I have a dashboard I could run a 30 60 91 20 when 52nd commercial.
And how does that work?
You get a piece of the ad.
Yup.
So per every thousand of years I get a rate like three to $5 per commercial
rents.
If I five 40,000 viewers and I run a commercial at prime hours,
that's 30 seconds.
I'll get like 20 bucks or something for like a couple thousand viewers.
So you could run for an hour,
that's 80 bucks an hour or whatever.
But they have to be,
they still have to tune into it.
Yeah,
they have to be tuned in.
That's,
that's like live action.
Like sometimes if I'm having a really funny stream and every was as much,
of course she'd happening,
I don't want to like interrupt with an advert.
Like it's a commercial.
Right.
But if I'm just playing a game and I'm like,
all right guys,
I'm gonna go take a Piss,
uh,
get some food or a snack really quick.
Are they going to read a two minute commercial?
But I try to never interrupt
the action.
And these too many commercials,
they used trailers for movies so it drives from a random,
a rotator that,
that that's how switch makes also their money.
So these companies paid switch maybe 10 grand to run their ad three this Friday.
So you don't get to choose.
You couldn't say like,
Hey,
I would like to have a Chevy ad right now.
But no,
but what I can do is have advertisers pay me directly and run their prerolls as
my stream and never run a commercial through Twitter or do an internal,
uh,
advertisement inside the show.
Like what we do.
Yeah,
exactly.
Or could you have product placement?
Well,
exactly.
Yeah.
You know,
it goes good with gaming.
Kill could kill.
Yeah,
exactly.
Well that's what I'm doing when I play on my stream.
I have my sponsor's headphones on.
I have the keyboard there and they pay you monthly or well those are the people
who support me to fight it.
Like you're up in all over the world each week.
I just got back from London this weekend.
That's you know,
big events Samsung put away from me.
So yeah.
So I have two phones.
Right.
I have to just have to in my phone cause I got sponsored by HTC recently.
Oh you had to deactivate your phone because I have an unlimited data plan so
I've been resisting.
But I have the new HTC m nine,
which I use for everything else aside.
I didn't even know the m nine was out.
Just came out when um,
yeah,
I think I got it like right as before the MNA was pretty dope.
It was dope.
So much better as the m nine.
Honestly,
I pulled up the family plan on team cars and the family plan on t mobile is
unlimited LTE dates.
My music player,
T-Mobile's your music player now.
I said mate,
she sees in my car,
cause I understand.
So this is uh,
a whole new world and I'm being introduced to this world of streaming.
I mean the world of component of video games.
I'm scared.
I don't want to be just sweaty on you though.
The world of competitive video games I was kind of aware of and I knew about
these enormous starcraft tournaments where people are watching it on television.
Yeah.
Korea.
It's still huge,
right?
Yeah.
That's why I stuck half one died.
It got so big that everyone was throwing matches for money,
throwing it,
oh here's 20 grand,
lose your next game.
No Way.
And then there's,
cause there's bedding because Korea's,
it got big really fast.
I hate to bad noodle.
People always find a way to fuck things up of what happened to the original
starcraft because that game was bad ass.
I don't think they needed to change it too much.
They could do just updated the graphics a little.
And what happened was that kind of ruined part of the integrity of the Korean
scene,
which was like the dominant,
those guys are like insane.
Like the way they practice,
the way they play.
It was like just clear cut,
more efficient,
smarter,
better than everyone in the world.
So when they're seeing was infected that way,
it kind of,
is that a cultural issue?
Like you were talking about Europe and Korea.
Is there like a stigma on it in America that doesn't exist and be we're up in
Korea.
What definitely when I go to Sweden it's like being a pro surfer in California.
Re Not everyone recognizes me,
but I will get recognized every day over there.
So like I'll be at a Mcdonald's and some big oh shit hit would have nothing.
And Are you here for DreamHack?
Yeah.
Cool.
But not everyone in the room will know who I am,
but that one guy will like my buddies from Sweden,
the team and Ip,
they're the best thing for Sweden.
When most of those guys walk around in Sweden,
they're recognized 2030 times a day.
That's like normal.
At least
they're celebrities or celebrities in their city.
Like a comparable to like a Dan in the Grano.
Who's a big time poker player?
Yeah,
something like that.
Or fill a,
what's it called?
Phil Ivey.
Is it comparable to that or more?
I would say more like the surfing analogy is probably better because I guess
those guys are in the region in the world.
Right.
Wow.
That is unbelievable.
Kelly Slater's.
Yeah,
well he's pretty famous worldwide,
so that'd be like fatalities at one guy.
I'm sure you've viewed he's done right.
Yeah.
He just does all sorts of marketing best Gamer in the world still,
right?
Yeah.
He was really good at quake,
but obviously,
yeah,
all the new current pastor to beat him,
you know,
stuff Raffa is like the best great player ever.
He is.
Yeah.
Shane Hendrick standing and whatever happened in that one dude,
him.
What was his name?
Immortal.
No,
the fuck's his name.
Um,
there's,
there was a guy who was a,
uh,
an Asian cat had his own,
um,
he had like a whole server and a whole a website rather,
God dammit.
Why haven't lived the best immediately in the early days was it quick file feel,
feel like his name is immortal,
but he stopped playing,
probably should know this.
And uh,
he stopped playing and started,
uh,
developing products.
And you know,
a gaming website.
And I think for a lot of those guys,
the actual game play is so involving like you have to plot practice eight,
10 hours a day.
Yeah,
I've experienced the lethargy of it.
Like cause it's like it's a novelty,
right?
You,
you do something,
you're so into it because it's new and exciting to compete.
Well a lot of these parallel MLB and the NFL players probably wouldn't be in and
if they are barely making a wage they would probably say it.
That's fine.
But it's not worth it.
Getting my head bashed in,
well I'm not getting my head bashed in,
but I am spending a lot of time inside.
I am neglecting,
my hours are odd,
right?
I practice like two little evening.
So a lot of my friendship hangouts have to be like weird hours or weekends or
when I have no tournament.
So there is downsides to everything.
Right.
So like for me the novelty has gone away a little bit.
Like I don't play many games anymore.
I'm not a video game player.
I'm a counterstrike player and so I don't,
in my free time,
I'm not just like,
let me just flip on my playstation four.
It's like,
no,
let me go outside,
let me go do,
I play ice hockey still once a week.
I play golf sometimes I,
I try to stay active because I would go insane being saddled to,
I have one teammate right now who's very new to the pro scene.
He plays all day.
He streams all night.
He's gonna make way more than all of us cause he literally,
he'll be,
he won't leave his house for two weeks and he's still totally sane,
happy,
like totally possible.
He,
it's just a way it'll,
it'll go away probably eventually,
but he's in that state where he's friends are online and it's not like you're by
yourself.
You're dealing with,
you played quake,
right,
with your friends.
Right.
He's very interactive.
We're all very interactive.
He loves gaming.
I was at that stage on time where I didn't mind not going out for the whole
weekend and I would just land with my friends.
After a while,
depending on how you've balanced your life,
obviously you,
you want to do other things
in your day,
right?
You want to feel fulfilled as a human.
I took up golf a couple of years ago just to do something else and try to be
decently skilled at it just for fun because name was thrash,
thrash out.
He won like,
what are you wearing?
Like a Ferrari or something.
I remember,
well he was like one of the,
Dennis Fong started started x fire,
I think a big company now that's,
that's thresh that x fire.
He was a like the best player or one of the best players of the time.
I remember watching that guy.
The first pro Gamer.
Yeah.
Watching him play in demos,
you know,
like Jesus Christ and then he came up with a website and he had like a gaming
news portal.
He definitely paved the way and of all the shows that we've ever done.
Joe Rogan podcast,
I don't think we've ever had 8,000 people viewing our show right now.
We have like almost 8,000 people doing our show.
We haven't done that.
Maybe before Jamie,
5,000 before.
Wow.
Gaming community.
We didn't even hit it up that high.
I wasn't sure if I can announce this last week.
I was like,
yeah,
that is fascinating.
This whole thing is just the gamer world.
Yeah.
He gamer fuckers.
We,
we've hit some new plateau.
I think with interactivity with this,
not we but like the world.
I'm excited for you to connect you to twitch.
I think that's going to do some cool shit for you.
Yeah.
I think we need to put this thing on twitch for sure.
Now it's just,
it seems to me to be,
there's a whole world out there of people that are involved in this that I just
had no idea about.
You know?
I had no idea that people were making donation money and that someone can make
50 grand aren't always right.
You know how often has been,
I mean,
how new is this?
How recent is it?
Probably 2010 when it really started until the last five years.
You Speak Justin TV.
Justin TV.
Yeah.
We used to,
we used to do Justin TV from the green room at Cobb's comedy club in San
Francisco.
I was old Joe Rogan experience before.
It was Joe Rogan experience.
We even have with them and they were like,
Harry,
we want to give you laptops in and cameras and stuff.
That was like when we used to do it in a,
we did it in my hotel a few times.
We did it in green rooms.
I do it all kinds of shit.
Remember I came with a bathrobe on the leopard bathrobes and for you and Joey
and I danced.
Do you remember the time we,
there was that dude,
and this was way,
way back in the day,
but he had some sort of a cellular hookup in his backpack.
It was attached to a laptop.
Was Justin TV?
Yeah,
Tyler dorm and shit and he had a Webcam.
He had a Webcam that was like on his chest or a hat or something along those
lines.
And he had a list this like set and they wanted to give us one of these setups
and have us take it around.
And I think that's where me and Brian like we just,
we just said we're crossing the line and it was just too fucking weird.
Next,
Joe Rogan has a Gopro on his head during the UFC fight night,
but that's what periscope is.
I'm going to periscope from this UFC this weekend.
Oh sweet.
Yeah.
I'm gonna see if I can get a service or a cell phone signal cause I think
there's a Wifi.
You might want to also talk to Dana first.
The bad.
Well I'm not going to show that fights.
I'm not going to show the fights.
I'm going to like periscope.
I wanted to periscope like me and Goldberg like a getting ready and fucking
around and let everybody know what it is and this is what it looks like on each
juice.
Everybody,
the people that work behind the scenes and show everybody Thompson Sigora and
Tony Hinchcliffe.
I'll just come down with,
I haven't messed with it.
Oh yeah.
To periscope is a streaming app where you use stream from your cell phone using,
yeah.
So we do it all the time at the comedy store.
The other day I took people on a tour of the comedy store.
I took him up to the belly room.
I took him down to the comics bar.
I took him all over the place.
Very cool.
I should do that.
You need,
you could,
yeah.
You could do whatever you want.
I mean,
you could,
could you show pornography with that?
You know,
I just got,
let me,
I just got banned.
You got banned again?
I got banned for doing.
Yeah.
What do you do in your free time?
I troll with my free cams,
but here it here.
Take it,
check it out.
Okay,
cool.
There's people looking at it right now.
You have to hold it up and down like for some reason.
Oh,
okay.
Very cool.
And so there's people chatting.
Edgar hurts the,
the rules of periscope.
It's trippy.
No,
Nudie knows like overall sexual content.
I can't use it.
Uh,
no,
no.
Uh,
like showing fights because they got an a huge trouble for a lot of people
streaming the Manny fight.
Mayweather fight.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
So they,
uh,
how I got banned,
no,
is because of the fights,
uh,
because of the fights,
they had to incorporate some kind of,
uh,
a feature.
So people were showing the fights that people could report on him.
So what happened to me is I was,
there was a bipolar,
schizophrenia cam girl name a Egyptian princess.
It doesn't,
I just go without saying.
Yeah,
it was,
I mean,
she was wearing clothes,
but she was just like,
it was so funny.
And all these people on Reddit were like trolling her or something.
So I was filming what was going on with this reddit troll and so many people
thought I was doing the troll that they,
they reported me and I got banned.
But a periscope,
periscope and Twitter look at it and goes,
well,
that's a stupid rule because you,
you probably have a lot of haters that would just do this every time you get on.
And I'm like,
Yup.
And then so I think they've kind of relaxed it for me at least.
At least they respect the fact that you would have some haters,
you know,
take your word for it right now on twitch,
they recently added that like even as a guy you can't be seen with your shirt
off on the tosh.
I did something funny one time where I killed the whole team and I didn't react
at all.
I got up,
put my phone down,
I took my shirt off and I walked out of the room and just have a funny reaction.
I would get like my channel would get shut down.
So that's like how New York City has that law that men can take their shirts off
so women take their shirts off because they can't do anything about it.
Right?
Yeah.
Cause like Ra should fear,
we'll walk around New York City every day with no shirt on.
He does it all the time.
Don't do cause building,
man.
Our society is pretty weird about that stuff.
Well if you,
you know,
if you're allowed to show mill nipple,
I,
look,
I am fully supportive of anybody who wants to be naked.
If you want to be naked and walked down the street,
I think it's symmetrical.
Well,
I just think the idea of closes is fucking ridiculous.
This is something,
it's not natural,
you know,
it's natural.
Being naked,
closer,
just we were imposing this where we're imposing as a society.
If you're comfortable being naked,
walking down the street,
what you going to hide it from the kids?
Well,
you're intimidating when you have no shirt on him.
It's too much like us Saxon,
perfect muscles and stuff.
So it makes some of us nervous.
Well,
you're disgusting.
So like maybe somebody had just eaten.
I said,
we're all going to burning man and we're getting a general good podcasts.
Brian's got,
Jorgenson has a twitch thing.
Oh,
no shit man.
Oh yeah.
Scott has 725,000 fucking views.
Call duty.
All right,
I'm going to give this back to Brian show.
There's a Barco.
Yeah,
you should have his little heart things.
You should,
uh,
the UFC twitch.
Do you ever play the UFC game?
Yeah,
well I have to do a some.
You know what I'll do?
I should,
I should.
I have to do some voiceover for the newer version of it because they have new
updated versions of it every year.
So this year I have to go,
I have to go in and like a couple of weeks I have to go in and
fucking laborious task.
I have to fake fights.
Big fights are going on.
Is there ever going to be a playable character of you?
Cause that's what one thing that the Internet has been asking for for a while.
He's having a playable Easter egg character.
I would have to do a lot of work to do that.
I'm not really interested.
You got to get up to like throw,
I throw a bunch of kicks and get video tape.
My body's going to say,
man,
you have a vicious kick.
I saw something on Instagram.
I was like,
I would've just got broken in half by that kick.
Oh my God.
You're kicking it up.
Hit you.
Yeah,
but beanbags don't hit back.
But it wasn't a bean bag heavy pot to it being bad feedback can bean bag area
all of the above.
So this where's this going?
This is,
this is going towards virtual,
right?
Like that's Oculus rift is the next stage for all the shit.
I mean that's all I'm thinking when I ended up,
by the way,
that's what Carmack believes.
Karmic and I were chatting back and forth the other day on Twitter and one of
the things that he was talking about that he's obsessed with I guess is Oculus
Oculus rift and the possibilities that that entails.
Have you fucked with Oculus at all?
Played like some weird like ocean surfing simulator thing but playing cash I
could feel like I'd get nauseous.
I want to try it though.
See that's the biggest problem they did.
The biggest obstacle that they have to get over is a lot of people put it on and
get sick immediately and so it's not going to work for them.
Yeah,
that's a thing man.
Like with motion sickness,
like some folks get motion sickness and some people don't like some people
can't.
Like,
my wife can't get on boat,
she gets an a boat.
She was like,
well like I have no problem.
I can be on waves and doesn't affect me and my kids are the same way.
It doesn't bug them.
I was worried that it would get them,
but it doesn't get them.
But some people like,
like if you're in the backseat of a car,
they,
they'll get sick cause you have to sit in the front seat if you're going around.
Yeah.
Like Kurt,
like what is that?
What the fuck is that?
Some people just can't take it.
I know people that came in,
we'll watch a video games on TV,
first person shooters or they get sick,
some equilibrium shift or something internally.
I don't know.
So that would be a factor with oculus.
I don't think it tracks your eye movement.
So if you want to look to the right,
I think you have to do this versus like if you wanted to look to your right with
your eyes.
Right,
of course.
So it'll be very stiff for a while.
Yeah,
that would be odd.
Um,
but they have those Omni directional treadmills that they're using for Oculus.
So you would actually get some workout Tahiti?
Well,
no,
you'd be playing counterstrike and you'd be running.
I think that's when my leg ranking in the world had really good down here.
Everybody's would dudes and start taking EPO and running on treadmills every
day.
He would have to do something.
I mean if you think about like competitive advantages,
if it's,
if it's all of a sudden started becoming physical,
if it's shifted [inaudible] gamers started being like super fit.
Don't be crazy.
Like you know,
you remember that dance dance revolution.
I love that game.
Makes so many people get in shape.
I mean it really did.
There was all these success stories of people who they want,
they got into it just for being silly,
you know,
play a video game,
but then silly all that hopping around got them in incredible shape.
Like guys,
we're losing like 50,
60 pounds.
The health apps on the Xbox live are amazing.
The wheat and the wheat,
my connect tracks my body.
So if you're,
if you're doing one of the workout videos,
like a,
what is that one?
That pf 56 chains but you have Chinese apps that actually tracks your body so it
knows,
it's like you need to bend your arms more or your legs or bending like cheating
you're trying to achieve,
try and do half wraps.
Right?
Yeah.
Well that's um Damn it Brian will the oculus thing,
I would think that eventually that would be like,
you could do like you could spar,
you could have like a martial arts simulator with like there's a person in front
of you and your fucking to Duke it out with some person.
Totally practice your little metta fighting.
I don't know.
I wouldn't be able to grab them.
That would be an issue.
Like you wouldn't be able to like there would be no grappling stuff but you
would be able to kick and punch and stuff.
Just started three d printing opponents.
Yeah.
The thing about grappling is you'd have to,
you were interacting with a persons body like striking is s kind of independent
because you could kind of pretend you're hitting someone and they react.
Yeah and they don't,
you don't really have to have a bike where Jujitsu,
you're actually manipulating bodies and they requires correct leverage and
you're actually,
you have wait,
you're pushing weight around but they could give you like,
no,
you didn't have to be fighting a robot that wouldn't work.
That's the way lighter first.
Cause it's like a two or three pound thing almost.
You're putting on your head what the oculus jiggle around.
Right.
But it's eventually going to be a neural interface.
I mean it's eventually going to be some sort of a chip to they stick in the back
of your head.
I don't think,
I think,
I don't think we're long for this world.
I think human beings are going to be some weird computer thing and the next 30
or 40 years I really do.
I don't,
I just don't see this last days are already fucking guys sitting in airbase in
Nevada just drowns.
There's a lot of,
I mean the small portion,
but it's a lot of the technology that we're working on now is also,
um,
exoskeletons.
Have you seen those?
I mean,
I know I can,
I understand what you're saying,
but now they have these insane exoskeleton suits that are allowing people to
carry hundreds and hundreds of pounds.
They,
you don't get tired.
Your,
your,
your body can do all sorts of things.
It would never be able to do before the game called crisis that it's just like
that.
Have you seen crisis you could like flip on your power suit.
It's like in visibility.
Super Strange.
You can like jump over a roof and she calls that Matt Damon Movie The new call
of duty.
Yeah.
Matt Damon was a Matt Damon.
Remember that movie?
What's it called?
Yes,
Louisiana.
He has that suit.
They screwed into his brain and he becomes like a super person because he's got
this,
why can't you get to like chill version,
you remember?
Yes.
He had to,
he had to go,
we've got to go to some weird place to be 100,000.
Give me,
yeah.
It was like a dystopian version of the future and everything was bad.
But the rich people all lived in the sky and some beautiful town where it
Sigourney weaver and almost squirting weaver.
Who the fuck was it?
That it was like the king?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
from uh,
fatal attraction.
That broad seaward Glenn close.
Glenn close was the mayor or the queen or whatever the fuck she was.
Oh,
it's us paralyzed and you've got a brain controlled arm.
Whoa.
Play that.
She's controlling this with this brain thing.
And how was he doing that?
How was he controlling it?
Is that computer interface?
You see the interface on his head up there?
It was.
Whoa.
It's true.
That's awesome.
You know,
having things with this arm all up,
getting disabled people,
the ability,
what am I,
there's an incredible story.
I'll talk after.
This
can be a single neuron so you can get a whole representation of a grasp and
another neuron nearby will produce a different type of grass.
And be sensitive to
different type of,
oh my gosh.
Picking up a drink.
twitch.tv/handy
guy.
Yeah,
he's a friend of mine.
Then I'll buy Matt myself and everything's going good.
Right?
I'm about to,
I,
I'm in,
I'm at,
I'm imagining to picking up the robotic arm omics,
omics,
standing,
the robotic.
I'm towards the root beer.
I pick it up as a straw to my mouth.
Ready,
close,
read it so extremely,
I can practically taste the beer.
Right.
And I dropped it.
I dropped them.
I somehow reliefs and my thought process,
I released the grip on the beer and the fans and if fathers in my lap and it
spills all over making it.
So that was one of the bloopers and that was funny.
But the next one,
because getting hammered with a robot arm,
come back.
Here you are.
I'm no,
he gets drunk.
Can you not control it with his mind anymore?
Yeah.
Maybe he's like drunk robotic
robot.
Well,
I mean that's beautiful because that's again what we're saying.
I don't think we're long for this world.
I mean,
I think eventually that right now is really crude.
That's like the model t of these fucking robot things.
But we're going to get to the Tesla of these robot things and that's not that
far away.
And then people are going to Google,
fuck this shitty body.
This is fucking flesh bag that I live in.
It's always farting and going bad,
you know,
getting sick all the time.
Let me just fucking take my brain,
stuff it into this thing that'll keep it alive and definitely,
oh and nano stuff is going to start overwhelming.
Okay.
So this guy know personally,
he plays with the nubs.
He was born like this.
He's got no arms or legs and he plays using his nose and his two nubs and he's
fucking good.
Wow.
Like he shoots better than the yeah,
he's like better than the average player in the world.
What I like,
so he's like a world class player.
His name is Mikey.
I did a little report on it actually.
Wow.
I grew up playing with this kid.
He comes to the tournament,
like I go to tournaments around La when I was younger.
He comes there,
he's sitting there smoking a cigarette.
He's got like a little like smoking a cigarette.
He pulls out his,
he has a wire,
he pulls out of his pocket,
lights up a cigarette,
a wire.
He,
yeah,
he like has like an assister and it's like an iron like,
like a,
like a hanger.
And he likes straightened it out and like curved the end so you can like pick
shit up with it and like he's really creative.
If you watch him play,
he's amazing.
Uh,
it's getting the chart room right now.
Everyone say hi from Jordan to Mikey.
Hey,
what's up dude?
He's a bad ass guy.
Cause just stuff like I did a report on him.
The stuff he does like that he's able to do drive,
skateboard,
surf fish.
Which rob,
how's he drive?
Like,
so that's what he's building a new car now,
but they're like extended pedals and like these in the text,
but foot shifters or people,
the guy in Texas is like much longer arms than this.
This is incredible.
So this guy,
how does he write?
Like when he's typing,
how's he type?
Yeah,
it wasn't nubs and his nose.
He types with his nose.
Yeah.
Why shouldn't switch weapons?
Oh,
he's dead right now.
Wow.
So he's fixing his,
he's talking about hi Jordan
saying hi Jordan.
It's that he's a homie.
Wow.
Cool Dude.
And his mindset is insane.
You know,
this guy is just like always just like,
yeah,
you just gotta live life in Britain.
And I'm just like,
dude,
you know what if people complain about such menial shit compared to that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
no kidding man.
Well,
perspective as a motherfucker,
do you know if he's ticklish,
he's died now.
I don't know what's going on there with these guys in the game without money
over their head.
So that's so counter straight workshop economy.
So everywhere you start with a pistol,
you have $800 the round,
the morons you win,
the more money you get,
the better guns you can get.
Oh,
how rude.
And if you lose,
that's like a big part of the competitive players controlling your money.
Because if you,
if you like forced by,
it's called where you just buy everything every,
if
you keep losing,
you're not going to have good inventory.
Hmm.
Wow.
This is a whole nother world.
You need to tell Mikey,
Dan heading the death match stream.
Oh,
he's playing a game.
He can't leave it.
He's playing a competitive little.
Um,
let's go and check out a different game check.
Let's check our grand theft auto and let's see if anybody gets virtually raped.
And when they do that virtual rape thing,
their key,
they key.
You have to hack into the game,
right?
Every people all the time.
You can,
you can,
uh,
go into like my,
when we were talking about when you're playing a game,
when they get in the game and the game,
you can go,
like,
one of my favorite things to do is go to the Strip club and then block the front
door and then throw in a flash bomb or something from gas and gas.
Yeah.
And they can't get out.
You could pretty much,
uh,
like captured girl shit.
That guy just went flying through the air when we tuned in.
This is one of the most fun games to play and just fuck around with like,
oh yeah,
this is the game that uh,
me and Jamie like twitch a lot together because we can just hang out,
spend three hours,
just fucking stealing cars going through a lot.
But you can go to the comedy store in this game,
hang out.
And there's a new,
a hack because the PC version just came out.
There's a new hack that lets you go inside the comedy store,
which now when you played this,
Brian,
do you play this from your computer?
Do you use x box?
I use mostly Xbox,
but the PC version just came out.
So I have an old computer that I'm trying to you I need,
Jamie just got a brand new computer so he's playing kick ass,
uh,
version of grand theft auto.
But uh,
the,
the PC versions.
Amazing.
You just have to have a good computer.
And I have like a process.
The graphics,
is that what it is?
Yeah,
cause it's graphics are amazing.
The road looks incredible.
We're k broadcast.
Why?
I just sent out another tweet.
Yeah,
the Pc version does four K so you have to have even some of the top of line
computers.
What even barely get all the options at high right now.
They made,
they made this game to last because a computer in two years we'll still have
problems probably putting this on mass.
So if you wanted to get like one of those falcon northwest top of the line
Alienware
yeah.
And that could play it in full resolution or no,
especially Falcon.
Falcon or an Alienware.
They're the best computers.
Every Joe,
they would be perfect at this.
Which one grant that you're trying to get them to send you one?
Is that what you're doing
for people talk at the same time?
Jamie,
what?
What'd he say?
No,
I think,
yeah,
those would be perfect for this game.
But you have to have the number one.
What graphics card do you have,
Jamie?
You have like the oven.
Okay.
One.
It's like an Nvidia and a nine 60 but I think everyone's saying like need like
do they still allow sli where they come all together about that than I do.
I just do that.
Back in the day when I used to make my own computers,
I heard then you had to throw it away,
couldn't take it,
shot him all.
They gave me shot a lot of our drives.
Right.
Addiction.
You go far and things
because you get real immersed in it,
right?
Yeah.
It's just you've got an understanding of limitations.
You've got to know if you're a crazy person.
I know I'm a crazy person,
but it's,
it's good.
Well it's,
it's all because I,
my brain developed doing competitive martial arts.
So you,
if you don't get obsessed with that then you get fucked up.
Yeah.
See,
I was going to ask you when you first got really into like wrestling and my
shots,
what else did you do at that point in your life?
Like not fun.
Right?
When I was 14 from the time I was 14 till the time I was 21 there was no nothing
else in life between 14 and 15 someone I forget.
That's why I like with gaming,
I love it and I always liked it,
but like you start to realize if you want to do something else,
you can't just kind of half and half too.
Well,
it's also when you're doing this,
you don't risk your physical health through with the martial arts thing,
like a lot of guys have a real problem like UFC fighters,
even boxers,
they have a hard time figuring out what they're going to do when it's over
because it's so immersive like every day and it's a physically demanding thing.
So every day when they get up in the morning,
they know they have to do their training,
either physical conditioning,
they have to do their,
you know,
all the different skill training,
whether it's wrestling or kickbox and wherever the fuck they have to do that day
when that day is over.
They do a lot of this for relaxing.
They'll play video games to relax and chill out or their watch television.
But it's super hard to transition from that to some other life because they have
a short life where their vehicle can save.
Someone gave you a computer.
Okay.
And this computer can only handle the graphics that are available today,
but the new graphics are coming down the line but you computer can't handle it
anymore.
You can't upgrade and your hard drive only has a certain amount of years on it.
Cane.
Yeah.
You can't change your hard drive and you can't change your memory.
You can't change all these different aspects.
That's essentially what it's like to be an MMA fighter.
There's a very,
very short window about it.
Yeah.
Yeah it is.
Because like,
you know,
computers of your hard drive goes bad.
You get a new hard drive.
And then also when the graphics get updated,
they also update the graphics processors.
Yeah.
So for a fighter they have this really small window of opportunity and then when
it's over it's fucking over man.
I mean there are very few competitive 60 year old fighters.
I mean it's just,
it is what it is and when it's gone,
there is none,
nothing left,
you know.
But with Gamers,
you got to think that there's gotta be an age on that to where you can't react
quick enough.
Especially first person shooter type Games.
I think that number has been growing because I think if someone like Teemu Sani
and Nhl playing in the Stanley Cup at age 40 and you tell me I can't fucking
play counter strike at age 30 like batteries better example.
Bernard Hopkins is 50 and he's a world championship level box or I don't know if
he has a title right now.
That's my point.
He,
if he can still do that,
it's still,
it's still be into it and,
and train and do everything it needs to do.
Like I know I could play video games,
especially now that you can actually make money.
He's an outlier though.
He's a,
he's a very rare individual and he is extremely disciplined about
his diet and his health and yeah,
and also his skill,
his skill level.
He has a very defensive oriented like Floyd Mayweather,
Floyd Mayweather.
We'll be able to like,
he'll be like 50 60 years old and his,
she's probably going to be fine and he probably won't be fighting anymore but
he's not going to be hit damaged.
Yeah.
Whereas like Reus Salon providing a call for someone along those lines where
it's like a very face first or aggressive style,
that guy is not going to be able to do that into his fifties he's not gonna be
able to be Bernard Hopkins unless he changes his style radically.
See,
obviously you don't comprehend all the nuances to fighting,
but I just think of that like to have someone playing a video game and I'm
sitting here like how can you tell me if I don't balance my physical health?
It's that I can't play.
Well you got to worry about your,
your reflexes.
I mean whether or not your reflexes are still maintain because they've got to
think with video games,
you're dealing with such a small window of opportunity for like getting a shot
off and stuff like that.
That reaction time.
Like do you take vitamins and do you fuck around with nootropics or anything
along those lines.
So there's this company,
they think nootropics recently just came onto my radar and I've been trying it
for the past couple of months.
A little bit,
but not too consistent.
And we'll get you some,
we'll get you some Alpha brand.
Gabby asked him to try it.
I'd love to do like a sample month or two or something cause I take a
multivitamin,
vitamin D,
he'd been 12 in the day.
I tried to do that fish oil each day.
But nootropics I did it.
It was like a coin or something.
I don't know the brand exactly how to spell it,
but yeah,
I've always had,
I've always been interested in it ever since I heard on your podcast first,
but I never knew what they're on.
There's a bunch of different ones from different companies and I'm sure it would
probably benefit you.
Do you fuck with caffeine dude?
You're drinking tea here?
Yeah,
I try not to overwhelm myself with at coffee.
Like I only got into coffee a couple of years ago.
Hmm.
Um,
do you try to do that on purpose?
Like to preserve your Saturday?
Like,
what are you coffee's one of those things where like depending on how little
sleep I got and if I'm going to compete right then knowing I just need energy
for an hour.
I'll give myself a little coffee 30 minutes before,
so the jitters the way down,
but I have that little hour of up at Enos,
but generally it was competition.
I have two rules.
I like to get sleep and I don't like to be on a full stomach when I haven't,
when I compete.
So,
but yeah,
that's a thing for comedy too.
You should never have a full stomach.
When you do stand up,
it'll fuck with your head.
It's like if you have a full stomach,
you're slow.
The blood out of your brain,
doesn't it?
Resources.
Just,
just,
just general resources.
I don't want to go down that line here too much,
but I wanted to talk to you about that.
Like when you first had what,
what sparked your mind?
I'm getting into comedy because I was always like,
I wanted to try to stand up at like the local camp comedy store in La Jolla in
San Diego.
I was like,
I just want to do it.
Like I don't just take a sec then just do it.
Yeah.
Is that,
is that what you do?
You just saying I go to an open mic night.
Everybody sucks in the beginning and there's no worries.
It's just to come up with some stuff that you think is funny right down.
Anytime you have a funny idea either put it in your phone or write it down on a
piece of paper and then um,
you know practices sorta like get the idea of how you're going to do it.
You have like or whatnot.
Well just be yourself.
It's the best.
You know like some people like they'll create a persona or stuff like that but
good luck with all that.
That's a pain in the ass.
The secret,
the secret is just being herself exfoliate,
exfoliate like who you are and just kind of be a clown.
I know it can be really good at self depreciation but deprecation deprecation
that is self deprecation.
Is that when I used to say that too.
It's because you're reading it.
Yeah instead of saying it.
Yeah,
but self self deprecation,
right,
because you kind of,
yeah,
it seems like no value over the course of the show.
Um,
but yeah man,
just go do an open mic night.
You're a smart guy.
He probably be able to pull it off.
Just try it.
Yeah.
I think if you could get really good at video games,
I really believe that if you get really good at anything that they're most
likely you can get good at anything that you direct your mind to.
I mean,
you probably wouldn't be a good linebacker cause you're not a giant dude.
Nor would I,
you know,
so it's like there's certain physical limitations,
but if you get,
you know,
you're really good video game player.
If you put that kind of effort into becoming a stand up,
yeah,
you could do it.
There's nothing prohibitive about it.
At least try it.
And that's the fun part,
right?
Yeah.
Well you,
you get better,
you know,
with effort,
with effort I thought and focus,
you get better,
you analyze it.
That's an interesting point.
Do you watch demos of your game?
Do you play play on,
we call him demos and then you watch it and go,
Ooh,
I should have done this differently or I have to work on that.
Yeah,
it's definitely,
that's probably the most tedious part of it.
Like you gotta make sure you're watching from both point of views,
your opponents and years and you'd be watching and yeah,
and,
and you're right.
That's how you get successful at anything.
And it was counterstrike.
I think that was one of the differences to me as a young kid and everyone was
just playing for fun.
But when I was like 1415 right away,
I started studying the top players.
This is what are they doing?
And I didn't necessarily do it.
They did.
It just gave me a lot of confidence to know that there's not,
there's patterns in some areas,
in another area it's open to,
there's variables.
You could do whatever you want and this type part of the game,
you could be good at this style or that style.
Just like in fighting the right,
there's a lot of different styles.
So I noticed that early on and I just by studying.
So yeah,
you just,
you kind of immerse yourself and figure out what your natural skill set is.
For me in counterstrike I had really good just like shooting abilities but like
early on I was so aggressive,
so hungry to get into the fight early that obviously if I'm not communicating
that with my teammates and I get over ambitious with the play then all of a
sudden I'm going to die.
Even like is killed two people and it seems like we should win the round but I
killed two and then went and died for no reason.
Whereas I could kill to play passive,
let someone else take the reigns.
Like those are things I had to develop more over the game and you have to,
you have to study that because there's a lot of kids who think they can be a pro
video game player cause they just have the good shot.
Oh I'm really good sniper.
Well what kind of person are you?
How do you communicate?
How do you like let your teammates play off you?
How do you play off of them?
Yeah,
there's a big difference when you're talking about team gaming.
Gaming versus one gaming.
Yeah.
But even just obviously knowing what you're good and bad at,
right?
So you don't just have ignorance when you go play someone he's really good at
something like,
well I'm just gonna fuck him up at this.
Well No,
he's really technically good at that.
You're technically not as good as him at that.
You should probably shy away from that unless you have some way to surprise him.
Hmm.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
Now are there different schools of thought like there are different like to do
people train people in this like do you have a coaches?
I give lessons for 60 bucks an hour lesson,
60 bucks an hour.
I'll teach you how to play for real.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
How does that work?
Like what do you do?
You sit down there and watch them and you do it on near beforehand.
So,
so that they give,
I asked them to assess themselves and they answered like 10 questions that I ask
experience,
how long they've played competition wise,
what they think their qualities are that are good,
bad.
Um,
and then we meet up after they fill that out,
we choose it's schedule and then we meet up online on the headset,
I picture in picture with their screen and then we're going to serve it
together.
And I just talked to them about some things that you need to know just about
timings.
If they don't have a lot of questions.
Some kids are shy or they just want me to lecture them.
So I go off and I say interrupt me when you have a question.
Other kids have a lot of specific questions about why am I not able to hit these
kind of shots?
I seem like I can do it in team death match,
Pr Team,
death match practice.
But not when I do a competition I seem to get really rigid and timid.
Why?
How can I stay loose when I'm,
when I really want to win and there's pressure on the line.
You know,
how do I,
so I just,
whether it's a psychological help or literal technical things,
I just tried to help people.
So with this seems to me it's like from the outside people are looking at this
like at some frivolous silly thing that people who really need to grow up or
involved in.
But from from an objective perspective without the cultural context of how
people look at video games,
it seems to me like a very complex multitasked sort of a skill based
competition.
It's,
it's problem solving at a very high level cause you're,
you're factoring a bunch of different things.
You also have social interaction with all the different people in your,
your group team,
our community team.
And then on top of that you have to factor in the playing styles.
Various different aggressive or defensive playing styles of the people you're
going up against.
Like this is a lot of complexity involved and I think the average person
probably wouldn't understand unless maybe they talk to someone like you.
Yeah,
exactly.
And I someone on when I said I was doing this podcast wanted me to try to
compare it to like fighting.
And have you talked to me about the,
like the Metta fighting in the small nuances?
Like you know,
you could tell like if a guy stepped a little weird,
like what does that represent?
This is right side hurting or something like that.
In counterstrike there's all these little things that I know that the outside
has no idea.
It just happened because I could see the guy's face because you've been there
because I've been there and I've watched it happen.
And the reason that guys playing so aggressive right now as a front,
like he has no health,
he has no grenades left.
He's trying to scare me away from the bomb site.
I know that's what he's doing,
so I'm just going to run in and kill him simply.
Oh that's interesting.
So it's what they call information chunking.
You know,
like you've seen it all so many times before and you know the scenario.
So you're like,
I see what's happening.
Top people play off that information.
Right?
Like writing.
I'm sure that's what they work off it,
right?
Well,
yeah,
I mean there's,
there's that you
like,
like sometimes like people say like,
how did you predict something in a fight?
And I'm like,
well,
I kind of seen it so many times before.
Like,
oh,
there's are also sir subtleties like from actually competing.
Like when a guy will turn his hips,
there's certain things when I know a guy is going to spin and I'm like,
he's going to spend and then they'll throw a spin.
And what it is is from fighting from actually fighting strength.
So you know,
he wants to do something.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well pretty mild is very few guys who don't spin anymore like a spinning back
fists.
It at the very least.
But spinning back kicks are getting more and more prevalent.
Like even Frankie Edgar who's like primarily known as a wrestler,
was throwing a lot of spitting back kicks.
Um,
it's just a really effective technique.
But the point being that it's just,
I know that it's going to happen just because I've seen it so many fucking
times.
It's a very subtle movement that people make that you have to like your,
your brain goes into that information chunking mode and they go,
oh,
this slight shift of his hips equates to that.
So if you see a guy who's like behaving in a certain way,
like I fucking seen that before,
that guy doesn't have any health.
Right?
It's like you're saying the fighting and it's a combination of thoughts and
things that you've experienced.
Boom,
it hits you.
That's what's happened.
Well,
that's with chess to like those guys that play chess,
they say that when they're playing that speed Chast they've seen this game so
many times.
I've seen those moves that blows me away.
When those guys have those clocks and they're slapping a clock and we will have
peace.
Yeah.
They're trying to play like seven,
10 steps ahead because they realize,
oh,
that's three options.
Four options,
one option,
10 options,
11 options.
Have you ever seen those old school videos of Eddie Fisher?
Bobby Fischer?
What does that movie searching for?
Yeah.
Well that was about Josh Waitzkin,
who is actually a Jujitsu player now.
He,
uh,
is,
here's something to do with Marcello Garcia.
I believe he's a black belt under Marcello.
Uh,
but Josh Waitzkin,
it was the s I think that was who they were designing that or patterning that
movie.
I don't know how much of it was based on real life,
but the Bobby Fischer,
the original videos,
it's really fascinating because he would play like 10 games at a time and he
would walk down this like conference table and just move the pieces,
like see if you can find Bobby Fischer playing multiple video games or multiple,
multiple chess games.
Okay.
And probably,
I think there's one stage where they're in like a little hall and he's walking
around and playing all of them.
And these guys are like thinking hard about their one game with him and he's
just kicking their ass 10 people's asses at the same time.
Yeah.
Well there's just,
again,
it's information chunking.
Like he,
he,
he looks down and to me it's,
since I don't play chess,
I go,
well,
okay,
I know that a rook can move like that and this one can move that way in a pawn.
Can only do this,
but he's got the whole map set up in his head and he's seen it.
And just to circle this background,
I think that is,
people do have a tough time when they look at counter Shaker,
when they look at quake,
knowing what to look for,
what are the indicators like,
what are the goals here?
And Keep Watch football or ice hockey say,
okay,
well they're doing a breakout.
This guy's floating deep in the neutral and he's probably gonna look for a pass.
Like,
okay,
like that's why the defenders thing back with them.
It's much more linear.
You're on one square field.
When he started playing these video games and all these rooms,
everyone's like,
what the fuck is going on right there?
It's still there.
Yeah.
Well if you watch like Floyd Mayweather fight,
like one of the things that's amazing about Floyd Mayweather is how he's able to
kind of dictate his opponent's move shit too.
For this.
They're like,
he's a pussy.
I'm like,
dude,
this calling him a pussy is so ridiculous.
That is probably one of the most delusional things you could ever do is cold
call.
Floyd was,
well he's 48 and no,
it was a professional boxer and a multiple time world champion.
Kind of hard to call him a pussy.
You want people to take your opinion seriously?
Yeah.
They just,
they get angry because they spent a hundred bucks like I want to see blood
everywhere.
Yeah.
They just don't understand boxing,
but Mike Tyson,
his movement though,
what's fascinating about it is he's able to take these guys that are normally
like high volume attackers and he slows their movement and their Slos,
their volume output considerably by him dictating how they move.
He just is so much better if they don't get comfortable and they don't know
exactly what to do because every time they go do something to get popped and so
they have to recalculate and rude.
They don't,
he doesn't give them the breaks and the openings that they're accustomed to
getting.
And that's all just because Evansville,
what's also is information chunking is just better than theirs because he's
putting more time than they have and thought about it more because he has a
really good brother or really good father rather who was a who fought sugar ray
Leonard.
Uh,
his father who trained him,
fought sugar ray Leonard way back in the day.
Floyd Mayweather see senior and then his uncle is Roger Mayweather,
who's a world champion as well.
And he's got other people in his family.
They were really good boxers as well.
So this kid was indoctrinated into boxing.
So his mind is like,
he's got all these and I'm sure he's a student of the game,
so he's probably watched a million fights and he knows what goes wrong when you
do this and just try to bring them down for other things not related to it.
All the other things are valid.
I look.
Yeah,
it just seems like a piece of shit as a human man,
you know,
I'm just saying that's what they immediately go to,
which is like,
okay,
well we're watching a fight like he's fighting talk about is like reading
proclivity or whatever they were talking about.
When people bring that up right away,
that is kind of embarrassing.
But he's here to fight.
I know it is kind of weird that he can't read but you know,
I mean that's a lot of money.
That's an unbalanced thing.
You know,
if you spend that much time boxing and slapping chicks,
you know have much time for reading,
you know,
and counting those out.
Why does she get counted the money yeahs that's a lot of money.
It probably can count but can't write well he,
I think he can read.
It's just a struggle.
It's just not very good at it.
You were talking about all this like intuitive genius he has and he can't
transfer it over.
Well it's probably amount of effort.
How much effort he put into reading was probably very little.
When did he,
how old was he when he went pro?
I don't know.
I believe it was 19.
He was in the Olympics and he lost a very controversial decision to a guy who's
like in destitute poverty now.
It's really interesting.
They had a,
an article about the last guy to beat Floyd Mayweather.
I forget what publication had it,
but this guy from some,
some country eastern block country,
I think it was,
it might've been brush or something like that.
Bulgaria,
um,
making shit up China
hedge my bets.
Um,
but this guy was,
um,
a really good boxer and apparently got a gift decision over Floyd Mayweather and
then,
uh,
went on to get involved in a bunch of shady characters and you know,
career fell apart.
But that was the last time anybody beat Floyd Mayweather.
And that was again,
like when Floyd was 19.
He's 38 now.
So yeah,
long ass time ago.
Good for him.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
there's lessons to be learned.
Even in the Shitty as human beings,
you can look at what they're successful at and even in the Shitty as human
beings,
there's lessons also learning what's the price of success and whether or not
you're willing to pay that price because oftentimes the price is foolish and
it's like if you have to become a bad person to be really great at something,
what are the benefits of being great other than financial success?
Yeah,
scoring,
getting those points,
you know,
accumulating wealth.
Is that more important than the way you're treated by your peers,
your community,
your friends and family?
What'd you you got to Blackbaud?
I remember the reading like 15 or something.
I think I was 16 I started training in karate when I was 14 it got super serious
about taekwondo.
When I was 15 before I was 17 I was a black belt.
So I mean it sounds like you obviously made a big sacrifice early on.
You've been doing that your whole life.
Right?
To dive in,
diving into things.
I didn't have anything else.
It's like your friends are probably in that realm right now.
Well,
not now.
Let me,
not a lot of 'em are comedians,
but at the time,
yeah,
it was my whole world,
but I didn't have anything else.
Like I was socially retarded.
I didn't have like anything going on.
Like I wasn't academically inclined.
I didn't like school.
I just moved into a new neighborhood when I was 14 I felt ostracized and didn't
feel like I was,
I didn't have any friends while I was in Newton where I was a,
it was a suburb of Boston.
So it was like,
you get it,
say like I sacrifice,
but it wasn't like I had all these friends that I couldn't hang out with and I
had like this family that was missing me.
No,
it was like,
you know,
my parents were,
I was a latchkey kid,
so my parents were working all day and you know,
I would,
I just didn't,
I didn't have anything else.
So I found this one thing that I felt like could give me some value.
I could have some.
I felt like I had some personal worth from this,
from getting good at something.
And then once I got good at it I was like,
wow,
this is the first thing that I've ever done that gives me like a good feeling by
being good at.
Whereas like my life before,
that was kind of depressing.
It was like going from one community to another,
gold,
constantly moving,
no friends being bullied.
I hated all of that.
And then the being bullied part is what led me into martial arts and it's very
minor bullying.
Like nobody really hurt me or psychological,
just being nervous all the time,
being scared of people,
you know?
And I wasn't a big guy,
I was little.
So there's,
there's like so many different things about it that made martial arts appealing.
But then the big thing was once I started doing it,
it just became my whole life.
It became everything.
And then that's when I realized,
Oh,
I'm kind of a crazy person,
you know?
And all I have to do is like find things and then those things become my whole
life.
And the problem with me was that that from the time I was 15 till I was 21 that
was sort of my developmental period of becoming an adult.
So that is how my brain formed in this like really laser beam focused kind of
insane way where I,
I don't give a fuck about anything else.
And that's what my problem was with video games.
Cause once I started playing video games,
somebody be talking to me if I didn't like what they were saying,
if I was bored I would just start playing video games and my head,
I'd be like I can be
quick or it can be fucking him rail.
Yeah.
It's like oftentimes people that are really,
really good at something or super unbalanced could resonate with different
things you're saying.
Well that's why I see with you,
I appreciate the fact that you have put a lot of thought into like doing things,
going outside,
playing hockey and getting a real life on top of this video game thing.
Because obviously if you're really good at this game,
which obviously you are really good at it,
you must have a sort of obsessive mind.
There's no way.
There's no like I have a quote that I use all the time that I came up with a
long time ago,
is that greatness and insanity,
our next door neighbors and they borrow each other's sugar cause it really is
true.
Greatness and madness are so closely related.
There's almost no way around it because you have to,
in order to achieve a super high level of something you,
you have to be able to do it better than the other people.
You have to have more and more of an understanding of it.
And the only way to do that is you have to,
you have to not pay attention to other shit.
You know,
you can't be learning five different languages and you know,
also pursuing a degree in complex mathematics and also doing this and also
learning how to play guitar and also having a girlfriend who demands all your
time.
Where are you going?
What are you doing?
What about me?
What about us?
Where are we going?
Where's this headache?
I'm not sure if you're committed.
Thought
about that.
Lately I've been,
I just kicked someone in the face and a number of double black belt and broads.
They want it all.
They want you all the time.
Where are you?
What about,
what about our career as a Gamer?
That's the best excuse.
Sorry,
I'm,
I got to play a video game for it to like legit chicks probably don't really get
excited about dating a super high level.
I don't have too many groupies abroad or here,
but abroad.
Occasionally there's like girls who it's like they have more like of a new,
like a respect right away you could tell they're trying to put their best foot
forward when they meet you because here and just,
yeah,
here girls,
when they meet you and you're their friends,
like their board,
their friends like,
hey,
by the way,
this guy's really good at video games.
They want to kind of have their wall up right away.
Like,
is this kid like,
oh,
he's really good at something.
That's fun.
That's cute.
You a lot of followers here and I'm just like,
oh sweet bitch.
Fuck you.
Wow.
Now,
but there's,
there's uh,
yeah,
or their video game groupies though.
Are there alerts?
There are,
cause there was like pool groupies.
I mean used to play pool all the time.
The guys who were like really good,
they would have girls that would like want to bang them.
Yeah.
I'm not gonna sit here and say that we have like game or orgies everywhere,
but there are girls who just,
they either linger or they come to events or they,
they tried to like interact with you in weird ways online so that when they do
show up at the event you like pay attention to them versus the other.
It's like,
it's like weird actions.
It's pretty funny.
Yeah.
That's a weird,
like they're putting out little seeds,
little flirtation seeds to try to get attention when they see you in the
physical form.
And then that's the best excuse of being a Gamer because you're playing a video
game you can make,
no,
honey,
I'm practicing really,
you're actually not doing shades on that computer
practicing.
So yeah,
team practice,
immerse yourself.
Maybe,
as he said,
don't get anywhere without it.
It is interesting.
This is the difference in men and women when it comes to what's attractive to
them,
because with a man,
it's not attractive.
That girl's really good at games,
but I mean,
it might be on topic.
Watching girls play counterstrike to me,
I'm always just like,
I had to look away.
There's few that are pretty good,
but normally it just immediately turned off like God dammit.
Well that's the same with standup comedy.
One of the biggest turnoffs ever is if you like a girl and she's a comic and
then she's fucking terrible and you're like,
oh,
it's over.
Gotta get Outta here.
Nice to meet you.
If you're dating a girl and she's a comic and she's bad at it,
you might as well be dating a dude.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
it's such a turn off.
She's got a chance to talk like a dude unless you're gay and then getting into
it is what you're looking for.
But you get my point.
If,
if you're dating a girl who sucks at something that you're really good at,
if for whatever reason just immediately kills any attractive quality that she
might herself.
What does she just like whip my ass at golf or something now I still feel like I
just,
some guys are fun like pools a big one for men.
They find it demoralizing.
Like they get very intimidated by a woman that was better than them.
Like some guys,
the,
even the professional levels we'll play like a really good woman or a high level
professional woman and fall apart because they're nervous to play.
A woman didn't want to lose to a wall and I could say from an it the past I've
played the best counter shit girl teams in the world for like events cause they
just happen.
They don't go to all the same ones but they have separate events.
When you play them,
it does feel like a lose lose.
Like you're just like,
I don't want to either crush them or barely beat them or if I lose then it's
even worse.
Like even if I win,
I'm expected to crush them.
And see you play them and you're just like,
I've lost like a couple of rounds like before I went any versus a girl.
I'm like fuck.
And to blues to them and then you have to talk to them.
Are you intimidated you like,
do you feel like insecure?
I mean at this point in my career I know all the best girls so they kind of my
friends in the game.
Right.
But yeah,
I'm
sure at certain points for the guys coming up they want to be pro male player
and they played girls team and lose their probably like fuck,
I'm going to walk out of the room quietly.
Yeah.
I remember watching pool tournaments in like say like a genetically or someone
like that would enter the tournament and someone who would play like really good
would fall apart in front of her cause they just couldn't deal with the
possibility of losing to this like really pretty girl.
Like they just,
they wanted to impress her and they were missed nine balls and just like shit.
Yeah.
The perception men bigger,
stronger,
faster.
Well it's not even just dad.
It's like men have to win,
you know,
they have this,
this I have to win thing.
And if you don't win your self worth,
like you devalue who you are.
I've heard you talk about that stuff in the past,
the caveman mindset,
right?
It's back in the day you just dominate your cave,
you hunt and you gather like you will.
The reason why,
I mean there's competition over breeding.
I mean that's really what I mean,
the competition over breeding is,
you know,
hunter gatherer competition and then it's like fighting off neighboring tribes
that have trying to come in and take them.
It's all like that.
So reason why men are such assholes.
It's all,
it's benefited the genes.
It's,
I mean that's really what it is.
I mean obviously we're moving past that cause you know,
as technology and society and culture evolves and changes and grows and becomes
more and more complex,
that stuff becomes less and less necessary.
But the genetics and the,
the proclivity,
the,
the inclination rather,
it's always still there.
The competition.
So when men to lose to women,
like especially in games like pool,
it's fucking drives them crazy because they can't just say overwhelming them
with strength.
Anything Ping Pong,
some chick wax at ball by you in ping pong.
How could he talk?
Damn.
Yeah,
Ping Pink is intense pink calms her interns.
I'm not interested in it whatsoever,
but you know,
Aubrey,
Aubrey Plays Ping Pong really goes like,
let's play ping pong.
I'm like,
let's go fuck her stupid fucking those bars though,
that have all sorts of games and I'm like,
they have like shuffleboard pool.
Foosball drives me nuts.
That's so stupid.
That's so,
yeah,
but it's just,
it's just,
you don't have enough control over that stupid fucking,
those shifters.
They don't have enough movement.
You know?
It's like,
uh,
yeah.
Pissing me off the ball going through the middle of fucking grab that shit and
throw it out.
Don't even get to it.
Sometimes it's like you can't,
it's like one of the things that I hate about when you play video games like an
Xbox controller was how like it doesn't,
it's not nearly as precise.
You get used to that was d on the keyboard and the mouse and you know it becomes
a part of who you are.
I have so many stories or like I go to like a house or a party or something and
everyone's like,
let's fuck a pro gamer kid and then it was like played fifa.
Right now we're playing me in this game and x box.
I'm like,
I don't fucking play those games.
Like I don't care to be good at them.
And they're like,
oh,
so I can beat you.
I'm going to get better in the pro Gamer kid.
And I'm like,
all right,
cool dude.
You're really sick.
That is an issue though,
right?
What's that?
Switching from a mouse and a KIA team?
Xbox.
I have so
much I could probably in counterstrike if you were to pick up all everyone,
all my friends,
I can play one on 10 against kids.
Probably playing with an Xbox controller one on one on five.
I've done,
I did it something from Microsoft so long time ago where they wanted to actually
see if the synergy was good to have like let x,
y,
x kids play me online.
And I played these kids one on four and I didn't even need sound.
I was just like running around killing everyone because they're so limited with
their range of motion that it's not just me.
I'm,
a lot of my friends could do this,
that or the pro level.
I'm not just some God,
but it's just the difference between,
isn't that something that they also put into the uh,
the game engine to make it easier to aim with those things?
Like auto aiming?
Yup.
And it fucks up the precision,
right?
Yeah.
And then everyone has these things that are extenders for the joysticks,
so it's like longer,
so you have an easier time manipulating the joystick.
So you know,
the little thumb pad basically makes them twice as long and that gives you more
control I guess
we called,
uh,
how much more control or is it more like a mouse or it's not quiet.
Just makes it a little plainer to all like call of duty and halo pros at first
person shooter pros use him on console,
but none of them are.
Yeah,
that's the thing that sticks up above it.
Oh I see a 10 year old uses that.
So it just makes it slightly better but still not as good as the mouse and
keyboard.
Why don't they have mouse and keyboard for these fucking things if she didn't
been nobody plays out.
No,
you can use Bluetooth.
We're now,
nowadays you can use Bluetooth keyboards.
Right.
And there's a,
there's a bunch of input lag when you use them,
but they do make them,
yeah,
that's what I had heard that there was a lag between what's not allowed in
tournaments.
So not you have to use those things.
Yeah.
Like I couldn't show up and just wax like a call of duty turnout.
But if I was able to plug in my mouse and keyboard,
I could probably,
even,
this doesn't make any sense to me that they would even have those fucking stupid
things.
Why not just have mouse and keyboard?
So that's the best input.
We always joke that like PC players or the master race because you know we
always,
we always say that that's like a joke between the communities were like let the
casual guys play on their Xbox and playstation.
That's what it is.
It's just casual game.
Right.
It's like I'd rather lay back on my couch and play grand theft auto then have my
keyboard and mouse.
I tried to twitch and kill people.
Yeah.
That's what's cool about the keyboard or the uh,
the chiller controller.
I used to have a thing called fucking,
what was it called?
I don't remember the fucking name was,
but it had a,
a,
a track ball and a handle.
Yup.
But a joystick and you would move it around.
He would shoot with the trigger was kind of cool cause you could actually shoot
with a trigger and you would aim with a track ball and track.
Paul was pretty cool but not quite as good as a mouse and keyboard.
It was like a step below the really good guys can still fuck you up with it.
But then once I switched over to a mouse and keyboard,
then all of a sudden I was moving with my left hand and shooting and aiming with
my right as opposed to shooting with my right and moving and Amy with my left.
That'd be a mind fuck for me.
I know people use that for like Photoshop,
I think balls.
Yeah.
They have like they just move it around but a track balls not nearly as precise.
A mouse not pry nowadays seems like it's weird because like games are really the
proving ground for like precision because it's so
critical.
Why?
So?
It's funny when these new,
these peripheral companies that larger tech or,
yeah,
larger tech is one of my sponsors.
When they make a new mouse,
they've,
they've recently,
the past couple of years they have the technology to make amazing stuff,
but they always add like little like ridges or something on the mouse that as
pro gamers like,
like to grip the mouse weird.
And the sensor,
they had these specs that like don't really apply to our range of motion.
They put like a million dpi you could track,
well I'm not going to swipe my arm across the room.
Like I have a certain range of motion and yeah,
I dunno.
The controller is essentially need.
Um,
I kinda lost my train of thought there.
But what you then have those Razer mice.
Well,
exactly.
Yeah.
When I was playing there was still a ball mouse.
It was still ball back then.
I know their laser now,
right?
Yeah,
of course.
But they had a weird shape that they had created that some people liked and
other people hated it.
I can never kind of get used to it.
It was a w it was way weirder than that back in the day.
The original raiser mouse,
these are,
those are logic tuck.
That's,
that's a Microsoft right there.
See there's that little like key pad on the top left.
That's weird.
Yeah.
But those,
this is not,
um,
that none of these are the things that I was talking about.
But this is new shit that they're doing.
This is one,
what's that one?
That split keyboard down?
Little lower.
Jamie are there.
What the fuck is that thing?
So since you know a lot of people DWSD so you get your left hand and then I
guess that's the right handed version.
No,
this is an idea.
This is a concept,
but,
but I played on something like that just for what?
In my left hand only.
It's just the WASD.
What's your theory at mouse?
I use a larger tech g 100 s it's very,
it's the,
it's the ambidextrous.
So it's very simple.
It's is trackball.
You'll find a lot of the pro gamers,
they don't need any more than like three to five buttons on their mouse.
Like the world of Warcraft.
People are casual gamers and have all these millions of buttons and lights and
switches.
And that's kind of fun because you have all these macro binds for the spells.
But for our gave me just like a something you can grip,
it's not overwhelming in your hand or has a weird center gravity or has all
these lights.
We just need to grip it well and have good tracking.
It's pretty simple.
Now if a new game came out,
like say you know,
there's call of duty and all these different games and new game out came out,
it became the shit.
And you started seeing that trend where everybody was slowly drifting off to
that game.
What do you do?
Do you decide,
okay,
I've got to fucking pick this game up.
And if you do,
are you starting from scratch?
Are you starting from like halfway?
Uh,
I guess it depends how new the game.
He's like current call Denise,
if it was on PC,
I'd be,
I'd be above average would probably be a decent competitive player.
You have to learn all the maps and then the metagame has gone obviously because
there's no information chunks that exist at this point.
The sport said literally new sport.
Now.
Um,
I don't know.
It depends,
you know,
like if the game has so much support,
how viable is it is a job,
what do I need to do to make money?
Do I need to win every tournament?
Do I need to just be a top hundred competitor?
Would you dip your toes in like in the,
would you start fucking with it occasionally and then say,
I've got to figure out what to do here.
Like how do you know where the tide's going?
Yeah,
you don't always,
but you can kind of tell based off like player numbers,
right?
Like counterstrike,
Grote counterstrike go.
The game I play is kind of had like an exponential growth the past like year and
a half still.
Uh,
yeah.
Recently it got to re insurgence because they took the model of League of
legends where you can customize all the shit in the game.
Counterstrike got a little bland for people because there was the same thing
always.
But now they've made it so you can customize the way your gun looks and all
these little gimmicky things that are pretty cool,
but they don't really change the game and that brought in new players,
new money,
which makes the game developer pool more money into it.
Keep updating the nuances.
Maybe there's a glitch and the old game they would never fix it because that's
it.
They're not going to release a new version when the next one comes out.
Have Fun.
With counterstrike,
they constantly updated and upgraded so you could tell how popular the game is
by just how the community vibe is,
how many tournaments are happening,
what not.
Like Dota League of legends,
they have tournaments all the time.
Counterstrike,
we have tournaments all the time.
Quake,
they have QuakeCon now.
They don't really have any more tournaments.
It just kind of slowly died down.
Maybe lack of interest back then.
They didn't have the same model.
The game developers that is to make money.
They will just release the game.
They make money and quake.
The players don't really have an opportunity to make money and what not to this
point.
Which thing?
Twitch.
Yeah,
so a couple of them,
like I know the top quake players and if they had twitch now and the game was
still big,
they would all be in a similar boat as I am.
But unfortunately the game kind of plateaued in the bubble popped before twitch
got big and they just,
there's no tournaments.
They just don't have anywhere to compete.
Yeah.
So that's what I'm saying.
How do you avoid being one of those guys?
It seems to me it's kind of all tell.
You don't really know,
especially if you're like a starcraft player.
Those guys play starcraft.
Like there's not many other shooter games or starcraft style games.
They can go play.
Starcraft goes away.
Your fun mobile has the most options.
So mobile is a multiplayer online battle arena.
That's Dota League of legends and heroes and new earth.
They're basically almost the same game.
One guy there,
they're literally one guy created Dota.
There's a Warcraft three brand a long time ago and it had like one map and
that's it.
There's like three lanes and whatnot and all these other games since there was
like the guy in the sky independently made the map.
I think it was mad frog ice frog or something.
I forget his name.
And Basically League of legends,
Dota and heroes of newers three different game developers.
They're almost the same concept game.
Everything's have slightly different heroes and champions and spells.
But um,
basically they normally say like people who can't go pro and Dota go pro and
legal legends.
People who can't go pro and legal legends go pro in here,
Hon Niros are new earth.
So it's like this succession of almost the same game but just like more and more
money and more and more tournaments.
If you put me in a time machine from back when I was playing quake and then it
like in the nineties and then jumped me here today,
I'd be like,
what in the actual fuck is going on?
Yeah.
I want to see this league of Legend.
Sure.
Show me some video gaming and streaming.
No,
no.
I just want to see what it looks like an iPad game.
But it wasn't so popular.
It's super casual friendliness.
Is it here?
Yeah.
So so it's v it caters a lot.
There's a shit ton of girls and the kids and God Jorgensen.
Just send me a text message.
Thanks for the twitch.
Shout out homie cause he's got a giant twitch.
So this is the game.
Um,
so it's the League of legends.
I honestly don't even play the game so I couldn't tell you what the fuck is
going on.
I know vaguely what's going on.
It's what?
It's free.
It's free to play.
It's really,
that was one of the first games have made their money model not off on the game
but off all the things you could buy in the game or transactions.
So that's Kinda,
I guess that was the right term.
But that's what I was talking about earlier.
That's what cs go has now.
MAACO transactions.
Those are really problematic for thinking phones.
That's why quake was never as big though.
Cause like if they had this model of micro transactions,
you could change the way your laser gun works.
So your rocket guy,
that seems like that would have been like,
I mean even though it might be a dollar $2 transaction,
if 300,000 kids who are doing it a week,
you're going to see some return.
They see.
It seems like they're fucking you though.
Like I don't want,
but they're like,
they have a champion,
they choose,
right,
and they run around and then these little like minions,
I honestly don't really even understand the game too much.
So that that guy with the green health bar next to him,
he's the main one that's his crew mob and behind him that
he's towers.
These are superheroes,
I guess.
Is that what this is not,
not necessarily superheroes,
but heroes.
Meaning they're just like,
they're super strong.
Those are,
you choose because they have different skillsets,
right?
One might be more,
have more defense,
so they call him like a tank.
He's really strong with his defense.
Some are better at attacking,
maybe they tagged better close range,
maybe the tag better long range.
So you check it's five versus five normally.
So the pro teams go,
they've,
they're strategizing a,
do we need,
I don't know.
I honestly don't know.
But they need like,
you know,
close range attackers,
the tank,
this guy,
that guy.
Did you play a lot of destiny?
No.
I would play it if it's on PC,
but I just honestly first person shooters,
like I can't spend my free time playing them anymore unless I'm going to
casually play it on this.
This is ugly to look out.
It looks fat acid.
It seems like I gave him that.
You would like to think,
oh you talk about this looks [inaudible] destiny the shooter game the other game
now.
And then I just never connected to it.
You know,
stupid and counter striking quake.
You see it,
you feel that you have in flow.
Their strategy is very intuitive.
He's go to go to war counterstrike one and let's just,
just for graph,
just for,
um,
so let's see a good person if I scroll down.
So there's not really any pros playing right now.
You can go to the top though.
Actually scroll down.
I saw named Robyn official one more down.
Right in the middle,
right there.
Click that guy.
He's an old Swedish pro.
He gives him a plane in awhile.
So this,
this is so much more interesting to me.
So he's running out of spawn right now.
Is this,
is the gun around?
He's got an AK 47 so,
but this is like,
you're watching like the map.
So he's going to see on the left here.
Most likely.
I just couldn't imagine why other games don't do it just like this.
He does that as teammate trade to kill it.
So it's good.
And then they got another kill.
So there an advantage or enough four hours,
three and a half to three verse three.
Nice.
What I'm talking.
Yeah,
I
pointed at it.
Right to kill us.
But this is so much more fun to look at.
All right.
Yeah.
Like if you're playing it too,
it's like it's so much more immersive.
Like you feel like this is going on when you're looking down and everyone has
like a bar with a health bar above their head and we were throwing spells and
you're looking down there just so bizarre looking.
Yeah and as I said earlier and League of legends,
when someone's getting out skilled or they're winning around,
it's normally like pretty drawn out.
Five,
10,
15,
20 minutes.
What's cool about cash check and very intuitive for spectators.
That right there you just talking about it didn't die right.
We'll also,
it seems to count it happens quicker with counterstrike.
The physics are very similar to real life physics.
Like you can't do any weird shit like you can,
you can do weird shit and quake.
We could jump a little higher than you really would kill a to in this game you
can't prone,
you could duck stand and walk and run.
Um,
you can prone in some games like call of duty.
You could like do some weird shit.
We like jumping and slide.
It's got supermanning I think he like jumped in like extended and lay down.
It's weird.
Wow.
Stadiums of people watching you guys play or final matches?
Like League of legends though?
Like Korea,
the biggest one I was at recent,
it was in Poland and we fill it up.
There's like a 20,000 person arena and [inaudible] thousand eight I was in the
final for that,
but it was awesome to watch.
So you were watching and these guys were playing in 20,000 people were there.
You have a video on my Instagram or I'm like shooting it over my shoulder and
everyone's like and Ip virtus pro and ice cream at the teenagers in this epic
because wow,
the arenas,
thousand people screaming that normally set it up.
Like every player has a projector to their point of view.
So there's like 10 projectors and then one giant projector for the commentators.
Wow.
This is the color of a play by play.
Where do you think this is going?
Like,
what do you,
if you had to envision,
if you had to prognosticate and you look at where games are right now and he
tried to extrapolate and look,
you know,
five,
10 years in the future when you think it's going to be,
not ray Kurzweil,
but let's see if I was ray,
I don't think it's,
I don't think it's success.
Basically.
I think what we've realized in the community and a lot of these top people who
run the companies realizes that like TV and the mainstream routes that everyone
wants to go like reality TV,
let's show the gamers behind the scenes.
Like that shit just isn't what is necessary for this world.
So what they're doing now,
and what I think it'll turn into is what you're currently seeing now.
Just a little bit higher production quality and more,
uh,
more catered to the players and they have an advanced,
maybe player's lounge is better warm up areas.
Like,
I think everything's going to be somewhat similar but tidy it up just enough to
make the,
all the narratives of the protein is more clear to the,
to the mainstream to make when you watched like to make all the information much
more presented clearly.
Cause obviously not anyone watching would say,
oh that's their ammo.
How much ammo to do some really what I was asking what I was,
I just saying I think,
I think that's,
I think it's going to keep growing and I,
and I think
you're not going to see these astronomical changes where we're like every match
is in a huge Madison Square Garden.
That's not really what I meant either.
I meant with video games themselves.
Yeah.
Like it seems
like the games themselves are getting more and more complex and more and more
immersive.
Like where,
where could this possibly type stuff?
Yeah.
Do you think that that's that that's a possibility like that the oculus rift
thing that comic was talking about,
do you,
you,
you don't think so Brian?
Yeah.
How come?
What do you think?
I think there's going to be something that's going to Trump that.
I think it's nice.
It's a fun little gimmick type thing,
but like the thing we were talking about earlier about get people getting sick
and how heavy it is and stuff.
I think in 10 or 15 years that's just going to be like a a Beta test of what
we're talking about and it's probably going to be just like a contact lens that
you put it in your eye and it turns your living room and that technology,
and like you said,
exponential growth of technology is insane.
We might just have one chip,
we might not need it at Oculus.
We might just have a little tablet thing.
We put our temple and all of sudden you're experiencing this with no fatigue.
Have you seen those goggles to turn the whole world into a desktop?
The video games
posted a crazy video I want to play.
It's called the void.
It's the HD version.
I'll show you.
It's Oculus rift.
Oh,
okay.
Here we go.
Go full screen.
Start it from the beginning.
Okay,
cool.
Graphics.
What if you could explore new dimensions,
new worlds
from your bedroom
where dreams become reality.
They build a space in a warehouse.
Imagination has no limits.
Whoa.
Okay,
so this guy has virtual reality goggles on unparalleled visuals and body
tracking.
Oh,
see you're wearing some crazy vest.
Oh my God,
this guy's walking through a warehouse and things are coming at them.
Oh my God.
Virtual worlds built over physical environments.
Oh,
this is it.
Jamie,
you just answered my question.
This is the fucking future.
So I definitely think like laser tag will get invented.
It's like little laser tech things will be definitely environmental effects.
Oh my God.
This is for the super casual player obviously,
right?
Yeah,
super casual per se.
Like single player Games,
right?
You're playing your own journey story right here.
Not Casual.
Meaning this is a place where you would rent out like a laser tag and virtual.
Like I don't ever see this taking over where it's in your house and no,
but this could be like an arena,
like where you play football.
I mean this could be the future where you're watching people play in a
warehouse.
So I think that's why my grandpa,
this is amazing.
I don't think this is going to be when your Grandpa,
dude,
I think he's going to be a game where you accidentally get your girlfriend
pregnant.
This exists.
Well,
one of those super soon.
This is nuts man.
These guys all have fake swords and they're,
oh my God.
This various games that you could play and they're fighting against dragons with
swords.
This is fucking,
this is all concept obviously.
Well it seems like they were showing the actual physical environment,
like they're creating it.
I think it's like a demo.
What CGI on top of,
well let's go to the void.com and find out,
go to the void.com and see what the fuck.
How'd they get the void?
They must have to pay for that bitch.
That's my plan.
I don't think that'll answer.
East sports says,
I guess why I went down the other path of talking like I don't know how that
would enter your sports.
Something that's,
so you're primarily concerned with the sport professional sport aspect sign
attached to pleasant Grove,
Utah.
And after summer,
so essentially a year from now I could see how bad ass,
what is that game?
Uh,
with the dragons recently came out single dragging haunted cat.
Look at what you're saying here.
Look what they're saying here.
Scroll elder scrolls versions of infinite dimensions.
The void is exactly what our virtual entertainment centers will offer.
Experience everything from haunted castles to dinosaur safaris to futuristic
battlefields.
And with our competitive or cooperative multiplayer modes,
you can share these incredible experiences with family and friends.
See that might be a weird issue,
man.
If these games started becoming physical,
if you start having these competitions,
like you're playing one on,
you're playing for other teams,
five on five or how many people are encountering driver's side,
five versus five.
Imagine if you're doing five versus five and these things and it becomes about
athletics and comes about athletes competing in virtual environments,
in video games.
I mean that really could be possible.
Sorta like dance,
dance revolution.
Get you guys in shape.
Like I said,
that's right.
I need that supersedes.
Then after that it's,
I don't need to get in shape.
I just plug in one.
That's going to be weird if people resist the getting in shape part this,
I mean,
who knows what,
what this is going to be or whether this is going to catch on,
but I think like,
why would you go to the movies when you could live a movie?
When you could go,
I mean,
imagine if you had like the Hobbit,
like that kind of graphics and you're actually in the environment walk through
the battlefield next to Gandalf fuck dude.
And they,
they figure out a way to sculpt the ground in a way that makes it feel like
you're going uphill and downhill and dirt under your feet and rocks and
different terrains.
We did figure that out and we're experiencing it in the past of our current
development.
Yeah,
the whole virtual reality right now.
Right.
Well that's,
that's the,
the mind fuck of all mine is that one day they will be an artificial reality.
It's indiscernible from this reality and how do we know we're not already in it.
We're in it.
DMT.
Oh,
people think so.
It comes,
I mean it does come up every now and again.
Jordan.
I think we've said everything we can say about video gaming.
Yeah man.
Anything else to add day?
I shout out to everyone who shout outs all you free speech
and a little bit about East sports today.
If you haven't got enough info from me,
feel free to look around.
Yeah.
And you could find Jordan.
What is your,
uh,
your Twitter handle?
C Nine n zero t.
H.
I.
N.
G.
So c nine nothing
[inaudible] nothing is your handle on cloud nine is my organization I compete
for and nothing is in zero g.
Alright,
well,
uh,
anything else?
No.
Thanks for everyone.
For watching friends and family.
Brian red band.
He got anything going on?
Telling people about,
uh,
we got a GK,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
I,
my twitch jails red ban.
So check with Kay.
I told him I counterstrike buddies had,
I'd say I'd give him a shout out.
Gk is a kids.
I used to play with some cash.
I say that at the end.
I was like,
yeah,
if I could fit it in.
Yeah,
you got to know what are you saying?
Twitter and mine was red man.
Me and Jamie play all the time.
Also,
I'll be in Toronto in July and a desk quad,
a Friday at the [inaudible] dot.
TV.
You guys are going to do a screw stream together.
Let's do it.
You're going to cross streams to dreams.
Let's test steps after the real extreme.
Well,
listen,
man,
this has been very illuminating.
This is a world that I completely was unaware.
I'm where I was peripherally aware of,
but you,
you really gave us the full tour of it.
I appreciate it and congratulations on being able to make a career out of this.
I think it's fucking awesome.
Thank you.
Kudos to you,
sir.
Uh,
and to everybody else,
go fuck yourself.
We'll see you next week.
Much love big kisses.
Oh,
Friday night.
Vegas is still some tickets available.
Uh,
that's tomorrow.
Thompson [inaudible],
Tony Hinchcliffe and me at the [inaudible] theater at the MGM hollow.
See you then.
Okay.